GOOD EVENING
EVERYBODY -- I'M GONNA CALL THIS
TO ORDER A OR ANYTHING BUT I'D
LIKE TO WELCOME EVERYONE MY NAME
IS BRUCE ROSS AND THE DISTRICT
RECTOR FOR ASSEMBLY MEMBER AND
ALLEY -- HE HE ALTHOUGH WE WERE
SORT OF BUILDING PART AS THE
HOST OF THIS -- REALLY HE WOULD
JUST HE HAD TO GET A COMMITMENT
IMPLEMENTS COUNTY TONIGHT -- BUT
THIS WAS SOMETHING THAT
ASSEMBLYMAN FRASIER'S -- OFFICE
BROUGHT TO US -- THEY WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT.
THE SELECT COMMITTEE ON
INTELLECTUAL DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES -- THEY'VE BEEN
AMAZINGLY AGGRESSIVE SCHEDULE OF
TOURING ALL AROUND THE STATE AND
GETTING TO ALL CORNERS TO REALLY
HERE -- FROM THE COMMUNITIES AND
DIFFERENCE DIFFERENCES ABOUT THE
SERVICES AVAILABLE AND AND WHAT
IS IT ISN'T AVAILABLE IN THE
STRUGGLES THAT -- PEOPLE ARE
FACING WITH SERVICES AND I'M
HAVING SOME AND I JUST THANK YOU
FOR COMING UP TO READING.
AND HEARING THINKING HE'S HERE
AND THANK EVERYONE WHO WAS HERE
ABOUT TESTIFYING AND AND IN THE
AUDIENCE TO SHARE.
AND ANYONE WATCHING ONLINE COULD
KNOW SOME PEOPLE ARE AS WELL --
THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE AND
WITH THAT I'M GONNA REFER -- TO
THE CHAIR SOMEONE REFER YOU.
THANK YOU SO MUCH BRUCE AND A
GOOD EVENING EVERYBODY -- THANK
YOU EVERYONE FOR PARTICIPATING
IN THE SEEDINGS HEARING ON THE
OF FOUR OF THE ASSEMBLY SELECT
COMMITTEE ON INTELLECTUAL AND
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES.
I DO WANT TO THANK MY COLLEAGUE
IN THE ASSEMBLY MISTER DALI WHO
HAS ONE OF THE VERY LARGEST
DISTRICTS IN THE STATE THAT MAN
IS AMAZING THE TRAVELING HE DOES --
BUT I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR
INVITING US TO HOLD THIS HEARING
HERE IN REDDING.
I ALSO WANT TO THANK BRUCE FROM
FOR HOSTING US TONIGHT AND
INSTANCE STANDING WITH US.
THE STAFF HAS DONE A WONDERFUL
JOB AND HELPING US SET THIS UP
AND I CAN'T THINK ALL EACH AND
EVERYONE OF THEM.
I KNOW.
A SPECIAL THANK YOU TO THE CITY
OF READING FOR ALLOWING US TO
USE OUR CHAMBERS AND FOR ALL THE
TECHNICAL SUPPORT THE CITY'S
PROVIDED.
FINALLY THANK YOU TO LARA LARSON.
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE FAR
NORTHERN REGIONAL CENTER FOR
YOUR HELP IN MAKING THIS HEARING
SUCCESS ALSO.
THE FAR NORTHERN REGIONAL CENTER
WAS GRACIOUS ENOUGH TO PROVIDE
THE HEADSETS. TO TRANSLATE THE
HEARING FOR SPANISH SPEAKERS.
THEY ALSO PROVIDE US WITH A SIGN
LANGUAGE INTERPRETER FOR OUR
HEARING IMPAIRED FRIENDS.
THIS HEARING IS BEING LIVE
STREAMED TO THE SELECT
COMMITTEES PAGE ON THE STATE
ASSEMBLY'S WEBSITE.
AND TO MY LEGISLATIVE FACEBOOK
PAGE ALSO LIKE ME ON FACEBOOK.
VIDEO OF THE ENTIRE HEARING WILL
BE ARCHIVED TO LINK THAT THE
SELECT COMMITTEES PAGE WITH
CLOSED CAPTION.
VIDEO OF OUR MOST PRECIOUS
HEARINGS ARE ARCHIVED IT'S LIKE
COMMITTEES PAGE AS WILL FUTURE
HEARINGS.
NOW LET'S GET TO THIS HEARING.
I AM ASSEMBLY MEMBER JIM FRAZIER
I REPRESENT THE ELEVENTH
ASSEMBLY DISTRICT THE DELTA
REGION.
BUT I'M HERE TODAY BECAUSE I
CHAIR THIS COMMITTEE AND HELPING
THE ID DE POP COMMUNITY.
GET TO SUPPORT IT DESERVES FROM
THE STATE IS A VERY BIG PASSION
FOR ME.
BUT THIS HEARINGS NOT ABOUT ME.
WE ARE HERE TO LISTEN TO YOU.
WE'RE HERE TO DISCUSS THE
CHALLENGES FACED BY FAMILIES WHO
LIVE WITH INTELLECTUAL AND
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES.
I DD AFFECTS ALL OF US
REGARDLESS OF OUR BACKGROUND.
WHERE WE LIVE OR HOW MUCH WE
MAKE?
R. IDG POPULATION CONTINUES TO
GROW AND WE MUST PROVIDE THE
SENSUAL SERVICES AND SUPPORT TO
OUR ID DE FRIENDS.
OUR NEIGHBORS AND ALSO OUR
FAMILY MEMBERS LIKE YOU DO.
IN THE CAPITAL WE DON'T HEAR
MUCH FROM YOU AS MUCH AS I'D
LIKE.
SO WE BROUGHT THE COMMITTEE TO
YOU.
I KNOW IT'S A LOT MORE
CONVENIENT THIS WAY.
WE DON'T HOLD HEARINGS ON
PENDING LEGISLATION.
BUT LEGISLATION CAN HAPPEN WITH
YOUR INPUT.
THIS IS WHY SELECT COMMITTEES
ARE DIFFERENT FROM POLICY
COMMITTEES.
WE'VE LEARNED FROM PREVIOUS
HEARINGS THAT LISTEN TO YOUR
STORIES IS THE MOST VALUABLE
THING WE ARE GOING TO HEAR
TONIGHT.
LEGISLATION HAS OCCURRED BECAUSE
OF YOUR SHARING YOUR EXPERIENCES.
WITH THIS COMMITTEE.
WE HAVE TO SET ASIDE SIDE AMPLE
TIME AT THE END OF THE HEARING
FOR PUBLIC COMMENT TO HEAR FROM
YOU.
SO WE DO HAVE A FULL AGENDA.
I'M READY TO GO.
SO LET'S GET THIS THING STARTED.
WE WILL BEGIN WITH A BRIEF
PRESENTATION FROM MS LARSON IN
THE FAR NORTHERN REGIONAL CENTER
AND SIR MAY MEASURE OF THE NORTH
STATE OFFICE OF THE STATE
COUNCIL ON DEVELOPMENTAL.
DISABILITIES AND THE FLOOR IS
YOURS.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER FRAZIER AND
MISTER BRUCE ROSS THANK YOU FOR
TAKING THIS TIME TO MEET WITH
THE FAR NORTHERN REGIONAL CENTER
COMMUNITY THIS EVENING.
WE ARE HUGE GEOGRAPHIC AREA WE
ENCOMPASS GREAT BEAUTY AND DEEP
SOULS.
YOU WELL KNOW THAT OUR REGION
WAS DEEPLY IMPACTED IN THE LAST
FEW MONTHS BY THE HORROR AND
DEVASTATION OF BOTH THE CAR FIRE.
AND THE PARADISE CAMPFIRE.
EIGHTY SIX PEOPLE DIED IN THE
INFERNO OF PARADISE.
MOST WERE ELDERLY AND PHYSICALLY
DISABLED.
FAR NORTHERN REGIONAL CENTER HAD.
SEVEN HUNDRED CLIENTS LIVING IN
PARADISE.
WE DID NOT LOSE ONE FAR NORTHERN
REGIONAL CENTER CLIENT.
WHY I HAVE ASKED MYSELF WAS IT A
MIRACLE?
WELL IF YOU CALL THE KINDNESS OF
STRANGERS AMERICAL THEN YES.
HOWEVER IT WAS ALSO COMMUNITY
CONNECTIONS.
AND RURAL COMMUNITIES WE REACH
OUT TO EACH OTHER WE REACH OUT
TO OUR NEIGHBORS WE KNOW WHO
THEY ARE.
NEIGHBORS SAVE IT NEIGHBORS.
IT WAS ALSO LOVE.
AS DEMONSTRATED BY THE HUNDREDS
OF DIRECT CARE.
PROFESSIONALS WHO TOOK PEOPLE
WITH DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES
TO SAFETY.
AND STAYED WITH THEM FOR WEEKS.
AND HOTELS SHELTERS AND HOMES OF
FRIENDS UNTIL FEMA ARRIVED.
AND BEGAN DELIVERING THE
TRAILERS WHICH THEY LET THEM.
THEY STAYED FOR WEEKS WITHOUT A
BREAK I'M TAKIN. SEVEN DAYS A
WEEK TWENTY FOUR HOURS A DAY.
THESE PEOPLE HAD FAMILIES OF
THEIR OWN.
THEY LOST THEIR OWN HOMES AND
YET THEY STAYED WITH THE PEOPLE
FOR WHOM THEY SUPPORTED PEOPLE
WITH DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES.
I MAKE THIS REQUEST ON BEHALF OF
OUR ENTIRE COMMUNITY.
THAT YOU DO WHATEVER YOU CAN TO
INCREASE THE WAGES OF DIRECT
CARE PROFESSIONALS AND LINE NO
ASSEMBLYMAN FRAZIER YOU HAVE
DOWN THAT YOU HAVE WORKED HARD
TO DO THAT.
THEY ARE WORTH MORE THAN THE
MINIMUM.
THEY HAVE DEMONSTRATED THEIR
WORTH AND THEY'RE WORTH IS
PRICELESS IN MY PERSONAL OPINION.
THEY DESERVE A LIVING WAGE.
THE QUALITY OF OUR SERVICE
SYSTEM DEPENDS ON OUR DIRECT
SUPPORT PROFESSIONALS.
THE PEOPLE OF THE NORTH ARE
STRONG PEOPLE PROUD PEOPLE THEY
DON'T ASK FOR THINGS THEY DO NOT
NEED.
REGIONAL CENTERS NEED
FLEXIBILITY TO MEET THE MODEST
REQUESTS WE RECEIVE.
BECAUSE OF OUR ISOLATION AND LOW
PAPA POPULATION WE HAVE ALWAYS
RELIED ON OURSELVES.
WE LISTEN TO THE DREAMS AND
HOPES OF OUR CLIENTS AND
FAMILIES AND WE CREATE SOLUTIONS
TOGETHER.
WE SHARE A SAMPLING OF SOME OF
OUR CREATIVE SOLUTIONS WITH YOU
THIS EVENING.
WE CREATE EMPLOYMENT WERE WE CAN
INSTEAD OF OUTDATED DAY PROGRAMS
WE CREATE MEANINGFUL AN
INTERESTING BUSINESS
OPPORTUNITIES.
WE ASK OUR CLIENTS HOW TO SOLVE
PROBLEMS OF ABUSE AND
EXPLOITATION.
AND THEY HAVE PROVIDED US WITH
THE ANSWERS AND WE HAVE
IMPLEMENTED THEIR IDEAS.
THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE
WROTE A LETTER ON MAY FIRST TO
THE ASSEMBLY SUB BUDGET
SUBCOMMITTEE -- ONE ON HEALTH
AND SERVICES ON THE BURNS RATE
STUDY. TWO PARAGRAPHS ON PAGE
SEVENTEEN CAUGHT MY EYE BECAUSE
IT IT IT DOES NOT RELEVANT TO
OUR AREA.
CONSIDERING QUALITY AND
INNOVATION IN SERVICE PROVISION
I QUOTE.
WE KNOW THAT THE RATE STUDY DOES
NOT DISCUSS HOW INNOVATION IN
SERVICE DELIVERY WILL BE
SUPPORTED BY RATES OR HOW TO
ADJUST AND USE RATE MODELS TO
PROVIDE CUSTOMIZED SERVICES TO
CONSUMERS.
AND OF QUOTE.
WE MUST HAVE FLEXIBILITY TO
INNOVATE.
EACH COMMUNITY AT EACH PERSON IS
UNIQUE.
HOPE THAT YOU ENJOY LISTENING TO
THE BEAUTIFUL PEOPLE OF THE
NORTH.
I WANT US START BY AGAIN THANK
YOU ASSEMBLYMAN FRAZIER AND
MISTER BRUCE.
ROSS -- FOR VISITING OUR
COMMUNITY AND BEING HERE TONIGHT
TO LISTEN TO THE PEOPLE THAT
HAVE A LOT TO SAY SO THANK YOU
SO MUCH.
SO HERE I AM I I HAVE THE HONOR
TO BE THE MANAGER OF THE NORTH
STATE OFFICE OF THE STATE
COUNCIL ON DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES.
AND THE STATE COUNCIL ON
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES IS
ESTABLISHED IN FEDERAL AND STATE
LAW TO ENSURE THAT PEOPLE WITH
INTELLECTUAL AND DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES.
AND THEIR FAMILIES GET THE
SERVICES AND SUPPORTS THEY NEED.
TO FULLY PARTICIPATE IN THEIR
COMMUNITY.
WELL THE STATE COUNCIL IS REALLY
A HAS AN INTERESTING STRUCTURE
WE HAVE OUR HEADQUARTERS IN
SACRAMENTO AND WE HAVE TWELVE
REGIONAL OFFICES ALL THROUGHOUT
THE STATE AND I KNOW YOU'RE
GETTING TO KNOW SOME OF THEM.
SO WHAT'S THE ROLE OF A REGIONAL
OFFICE WELL IT'S TO ADVOCATE TO
IMPROVE THE SERVICE SYSTEM HELP
CONNECT PEOPLE TO SERVICES AND
AND SUPPORTS.
WE PROVIDE TRAINING INFORMATION.
WE MONITOR LEGISLATION.
AND WE IDENTIFY UNMET NEEDS IN
THE SERVICE SYSTEM.
SO IT GETS EVEN MORE INTERESTING
HERE IS THAT EVERY FIVE YEARS.
THE STATE COUNCIL IN
COLLABORATION WITH THE WHOLE
ENTIRE COMMUNITY THROUGHOUT THE
FIFTY EIGHT COUNTIES.
OF HEARING FROM THE PEOPLE OF
PEOPLE WITH DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES AND THEIR FAMILIES
WE GET INPUT TO DEVELOP A FIVE
YEAR PLAN.
AND THAT PLAN IDENTIFIES GOALS
AND OBJECTIVES.
THAT ARE WAYS TO IMPROVE THE
SERVICE SYSTEM [INAUDIBLE]
SO.
CURRENTLY WE HAVE SIX WE CALL ON
FEDERAL AREAS OF EMPHASIS OR
GOALS.
AND THOSE ARE SELF ADVOCACY
[INAUDIBLE]
EMPLOYMENT [INAUDIBLE]
HOUSING.
HEALTH AND SAFETY [INAUDIBLE]
EDUCATION.
IN FORMAL AND INFORMAL COMMUNITY
SPORTS.
SO THOSE ARE THE KINDS OF THINGS
THAT WERE WORKING ON EVERY DAY.
TO TRY TO CHIP AWAY AND IMPROVE
THE MAKE A DIFFERENCE IN OUR
SERVER SYSTEM ON BEHALF.
OF THE FOLKS THAT WE REPRESENT.
SO EVERY YEAR WHAT WE DO IS WE
SAY WE NEED TO COME EVERY YEAR
WE NEED TO CHECK IN WE NEED TO
DO AN ASSESSMENT SAY.
IS THIS WORKING ARE WE ARE WE
MAKING A DIFFERENCE SO WHAT WE
DO IS WE GATHER ALL THE PEOPLE
THROUGHOUT THOSE COMMUNITIES AND
FIND OUT EVERY YEAR.
OF THAT FIVE YEAR PLAN.
AND SAY WHAT'S WORKING WHAT'S
NOT WHAT ARE THE BARRIERS.
AND WHAT ARE SOME ACTIVITIES TO
ADDRESS THOSE BARRIERS
[INAUDIBLE]
SO WHAT.
IN OUR LAST ASSESSMENT IN OUR
REGION IN OUR NINE COUNTY REGION
AND WE FOUND THAT HOUSING
EMPLOYMENT AND HEALTH CARE.
WHERE THE TOP UNMET NEEDS?
AND SO I PROVIDED FOR YOU AND
HOPEFULLY FOR EVERYONE IN THE
AUDIENCE HERE -- I HAND OUT.
THAT IS DE TELLY THAT
INFORMATION.
SO IN THE LAST TWO YEARS WE'VE
HURDLE ALREADY FROM LAURA BUT IN
THE LAST TWO YEARS THE NORTH
STATE HAS SURVIVED.
THE OROVILLE DAM SPILL WAY
EMERGENCY.
THE CAR FIRE.
IN THE RECENT CAMPFIRE AND I
PERSONALLY LIVE IN THE CAMP FIRE
SCARS ZONE AS THEY SAY.
AND CONTINUE TO BE HUMBLED BY
THE COURAGE AND STRENGTH OF OUR
COMMUNITY.
SO MANY PEOPLE WITH
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES AND
THEIR FAMILIES LOST EVERYTHING
INCLUDING THE STAFF IN THE
AGENCIES THAT LOST HOUSING.
FACILITIES AND STAFF.
I'VE BEEN IMPRESSED WITH HOW HOW
SO MANY PEOPLE.
KEEP ON KEEPIN ON IN SPITE.
DESPITE ALL THAT HAS HAPPENED.
AND MANY OF THOSE HEROES ARE IN
THIS ROOM TONIGHT.
WE HOPE FOR POSITIVE RESULTS
FROM THE RATE STUDY THAT THAT
PROVIDES BETTER PAY FOR DIRECT
SERVICE PROFESSIONALS.
IT IS SO DESERVED.
WE ARE GRATEFUL FOR THE ASSEMBLY
SELECT COMMITTEE ON INTELLECTUAL
AND DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES
WHO ARE LISTENING TO PEOPLE
THROUGHOUT THE ENTIRE STATE
ABOUT WHAT MATTERS TO PEOPLE AND
HOW TO LIVE A GOOD LIFE.
I'D LIKE TO CLOSE BY SHARING
SOME INTERESTING FACTS.
ABOUT THE NORTH STATE REGION.
WE ALL KNOW THIS ONE NOW IT
CONSISTS OF NINE COUNTIES.
IT'S OVER THREE THIRTY THOUSAND
SQUARE MILES.
IT'S GOT OVER SIX HUNDRED IS
ALMOST SIX HUNDRED EIGHTEEN
THOUSAND RESIDENTS.
AND OVER EIGHT THOUSAND PEOPLE
ARE SERVED BY FAR NORTHERN
REGIONAL CENTER ALL YEAH WE'RE
ONE OF THE FEW REGIONAL OFFICES
OF THE STATE COUNCIL THAT WORKS
WITH ONLY ONE AND THE BEST.
REGIONAL CENTER.
SO WHAT I THOUGHT ABOUT.
THIS EVENING AND I THOUGHT ABOUT
REPRESENTING OUR REGION AND
BEING SO HONORED TO BE PART OF
IT.
I WROTE THESE WORDS IT'S A
LITTLE SILLY BUT I THINK IT
REFLECTS OUR AREA.
FROM SISKIYOU COUNTY IN THE
NORTH TO BUTTE COUNTY IN THE
SOUTH.
THE PEOPLE ARE AS DIVERSE AS THE
LAND ITSELF [INAUDIBLE]
THANK YOU.
I WANT TO THANK YOU LAWRENCE OR
AND AND I AGREE YOU DO HAVE A OF
A WONDERFUL.
COMMUNITY THAT YOU'RE SUPPORTING --
WE NEED TO BE ABLE TO SUPPORT
YOU FROM SACRAMENTO IN IT IN A
BETTER FASHION AND THAT'S WHAT
WE'RE CONNECTING TO DO SO.
SO THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE
TODAY AND WILL WILL CONNECT
AFTER THE THE HEARING ALSO.
SO WE'RE GONNA MOVE OVER TO THE
SELF HELP ACT ADVOCATES I THINK
YOU KNOW WHO YOU ARE -- RATHER
THAN ME TRYING TO PRONOUNCE YOUR
NAME SOME BUTCHERING THEM --
PLEASE STATE YOUR NAME AS YOU
COME UP TO SHARE YOUR STORY.
AND WE'LL START WITH ANY
[INAUDIBLE]
GOOD EVENING
.
ALL RIGHT THERE WE GO.
TESTING TESTING OKAY.
THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE TO
SUPPORT INDIVIDUALS.
WITH DISABILITIES AND OUR
COMMUNITY.
MY NAME IS AMY FACA.
I AM A FAR NORTHERN CLIENT.
AND I AM A MOTHER OF THREE I
LIVE IN MY OWN HOME.
AND I APPRECIATE EVERY SINGLE
SERVICE.
AVAILABLE TO INDIVIDUALS WITH
DISABILITIES IN OUR AREA.
BUT I BELIEVE WE CAN DO MORE.
I CURRENTLY WORK FOR WE CARE A
LOT FOUNDATION.
THEY PROVIDE TRAINING AND
SUPPORT FOR INDIVIDUALS WITH
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES AND
OUR COMMUNITY.
AS A PEER INSTRUCTOR AND LIFE
GUIDE I TEACH MY PEERS ABOUT
IMPORTANT TOPICS FOR PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES.
I WORK FOR THE VOTE PROJECT.
WHICH TEACHES PEOPLE ABOUT THEIR
RIGHT TO VOTE.
AND HOW TO VOTE.
WE ALSO HELP PEOPLE UNDERSTAND
WHAT IT IS THAT IS ON THEIR
BALLOT.
I ALSO WORK FOR WEIGHT WORK.
A PROGRAM THAT TEACHES PEOPLE.
EMPLOYMENT SKILLS THAT NOT ONLY
HELP.
THEM GET A JOB BUT ALSO KEEP IT.
EMPLOYMENT IS VERY IMPORTANT FOR
PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES AT HOPE
SAYS BE INDEPENDENT AND HAVE A
BETTER LIFE.
GOVERNMENT SUPPORT OF THESE
PROGRAMS WELL IMPROVE THE LIVES
OF PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES
THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
HOUSING IS ANOTHER IMPORTANT
AREA FOR PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES.
AFFORDABLE HOUSING IS KEY TO
MORE PEOPLE LIVING INDEPENDENTLY.
IF WE WANT TO MOVE SUCCESSFULLY
AWAY FROM AND THE TWO SINGLE
LIVING WE NEED TO HELP PEOPLE
GET OUT.
ON THEIR OWN AND LIVE
INDEPENDENTLY.
AND FINALLY I WOULD LIKE TO TALK
ABOUT STOPPING.
IT TAKES A LONG TIME TO HIRE AND
TRAIN SOMEONE TO WORK WITH
PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES.
UNFORTUNATELY A LOT OF THESE
STAFF ARE ONLY MAKING MINIMUM
WAGE.
IT MAKES IT DIFFICULT TO KEEP
GOOD STAFF WHEN THEY CANNOT LIVE
ON THE WAY.
TO THAT THEY ARE MAKING AN
INCREASE FUNDING FOR THESE
PROGRAMS WHAT HOPE AGENCIES
HIGHER AND KEEP BETTER EMPLOYEES.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY.
AS A WONDERFUL PRESENTATION
THANK YOU.
DO YOU WANT.
I'M GONNA HAVE WILLIAM ANDREW
AND ANDREAS COME UP.
ALL THE SAME TIME AND WE JUST GO
IN THE ORDER THAT -- OF THE
AGENDA THAT WAY WE CAN.
FACILITATE -- JUST HANDING THE
MIKE OVER.
ANDREW YOU'RE RIGHT HERE.
WE'LL PLAY MUSICAL CHAIRS FOR A
FEW SECONDS.
SO WE'LL START WITH THE ANDREW.
GOOD EVENING AND THANK YOU FOR
BEING HERE.
GOOD EVENING TO YOU TILL AND
THANK YOU FOR TAKING THIS TIME
TO COME HERE AND LISTEN.
TO THE NEEDS OF THE COMMUNITY.
MY NAME IS ANDREW LAMMERS MUST
YOU PEOPLE KNOW ME IN TOWN.
WHEN I WAS ABOUT NINETEEN I JUST
MOVED OUT?
I MOVED FROM MY PARENTS HOME
INTO A GROUP HOME.
THE CONDITIONS IN THAT HOME WERE
NOT GOOD.
THE FOOD WAS SO BAD IT MADE ME
SICK.
I ONLY LIVED THERE IN THAT HOME
FOR FOR MUCH -- I WAS THANKFUL
THAT I HAD PARENTS THAT HELP ME
MOVE TO A BETTER HOME.
BUT A LOT OF PEOPLE DON'T HAVE
THAT.
I AM MOVED TO ANOTHER.
CARE HOME AND THERE I HAD TO
DEAL WITH BAD BOOKS.
AND PEOPLE WERE STILL IN MY
THINGS [INAUDIBLE]
AFTER THAT.
MY PARENTS HELP ME MOVE INTO AN
APARTMENT.
I HAD BEEN LUCKY THAT I HAVE
BEEN.
I HAVE PARENTS TO SUPPORT ME BUT
A LOT OF PEOPLE DON'T HAVE THAT.
ONE OF THESE THEMES THAT PEOPLE
WITH.
DISABILITIES NEEDS IS HELP
MOVING INTO THEIR OWN PLACE.
THEY NEED PEOPLE TO HELP THEM
WITH THAT.
THERE NEEDS NEED TO BE BETTER.
BETTER TRAINED.
FOR PEOPLE THAT WORK WITH PEOPLE
WITH DISABILITIES.
THEY NEED TO LEARN HOW TO HELP
[INAUDIBLE]
US MORE.
WE ARE STILL.
WE ALSO NEED MORE.
LAW -- LOW COST HOUSING.
EIGHTEEN AND APARTMENT BECAUSE A
LOT OF MONEY.
AND A LOT OF PEOPLE DON'T HAVE
THE MONEY TO LIVE IN THEIR OWN
PLACE -- IN ADDITION.
PROVIDING JOBS FOR PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES.
WOULD HELP TO A WHAT.
TO A LOT OF PEOPLE WHO WANT TO
WORK.
BUT IT IS REALLY HARD TO GET A
JOB WHEN YOU HAVE A DISABILITY.
YOU CAN DO A LOT OF THINGS.
EVEN THROUGH HAVE AN A
DISABILITY.
BUT EVEN [INAUDIBLE]
EACH [INAUDIBLE]
TEACH -- MY MY PEERS HOW TO VOTE
AND JOB SKILLS WOULD OUT
PROGRAMS.
WHY WE CARE A LOT [INAUDIBLE]
I WILL.
I FEEL LIKE.
I HAVE NO -- PURPOSE.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME.
AND DO YOU DO MAYES AND SO.
I WANT TO CALL A FAMILY ALSO.
I MISS IT ON MY AGENDA IS TAMMY
ON THE AUDIENCE.
COME ON UP ON A CHAIR WITH US
PLEASE -- THE WILL MOVE THROUGH --
TO RIGHT NOW WILLIAM.
THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE.
THIS WILLIAM I'M A CLIENT OF FOR
NORTHERN REGIONAL CENTER.
AND I'M ALSO ON THE BOARD OF
DIRECTORS FOR FOR NORTH AND
REGIONAL CENTER.
I HAVE LIVED HERE IN CHESTER
COUNTY ALL MY LIFE.
AND I APPRECIATE YOU TAKING THE
TIME TO LEARN ABOUT OUR SERVICES
IN OUR COMMUNITY I CURRENTLY
WORK AT WE CARE A LOT FOUNDATION
THROUGH.
MY WORK I TEACH PEOPLE ABOUT
ABUSE PREVENTION.
EMERGENCY PREPAREDNESS AND
BOWLING.
WHAT THE FIRES THAT WE HAD IN
OUR COMMUNITY AND THE LAST HERE
FILLING SAFE BEING SAFE?
EMERGENCY PREPAREDNESS PROGRAM
IS MORE IMPORTANT THAN EVER.
IT TEACHES EVERYONE IN.
THE COMMUNITY WELL GET IN THERE
TO GO BACK TO READY.
BOWLING TEACHES KIDS.
ON HOW TO BE AN ALLY AND HOT
WAYS TO STOP PULLING.
I MAKE A COMMUNITY SAFE AND
BETTER PLACE TO LIVE ANOTHER
ISSUE FOR ME IS.
IT'S IMPORTANT FOR PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES TO HAVE JOBS.
IT'S HARD TO FIND JOBS AND A LOT
OF EMPLOYEE LAWYERS DO NOT WANT
TO HIRE PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES.
THEY DON'T REALLY BELIEVE WE
COULD DO ANYTHING.
HAVING JOBS WILL HELP PEOPLE IN
MORE INDEPENDENT AND BE
SUCCESSFUL THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME.
THANK YOU WILL.
I REALLY APPRECIATE YOU BEING ON
THE BOARD OF DIRECTORS ALSO IS
SKIN IN THE GAME THANK YOU.
SUNDRESS.
I ALWAYS DO THIS BUT I KNOW WHO
I AM.
YOU ARE NOT JUST LOOK AT THAT
SOMEBODY HAS TALKED A LOT BUT
YOU'RE LOOKING AT THE BIGGEST
EXPERIENCE.
THAT GOES WAY BACK.
I WAS BORN WITH TO DISABILITIES.
THAT I DON'T CARE TO TALK ABOUT
HOW RIGHT NOW BECAUSE IS NOT THE
PLACE AND TIME.
BUT I HAD PEOPLE TELL ME WHAT I
COULDN'T DO.
BUT I'M ONE THAT DID NOT LAST
LONG AND THANK GOD WE DON'T HAVE
MANY MORE BUT I FIRST WENT TO
SONOMA STATE HOSPITAL.
GOT OUT OF THE REAL FAST.
AND WENT INTO TO CARE HOMES AND
FROM THE TO CARE HOMES THE
SECOND ONE WAS TRASH BECAUSE
THEY REALLY.
BUT THAT COULD BE USED BY TELL
ME WHAT I COULDN'T DO.
NOW A LOT OF YOU'VE ALREADY SEEN
ENOUGH PROOF.
THAT PEOPLE DISABILITIES CAN DO
WHAT THEY WANT TO DO AND LIVES
ALSO YOU HAVE BEEN EMPLOYEES
KNOW THAT WHEN PEOPLE
DISABILITIES HAVE A JOB.
THEY TRY THEIR BEST TO KEEP IT.
THAT FINALLY HAPPENED TO BE IN
MY LIFE EVEN ALL THE OTHER
THINGS I'VE DONE LIKE BEING A
LAY MINISTER FOR PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES.
AND BECAUSE OF THAT THAT'S WHAT
GAVE ME THE CHANCE TO BE A PART
OF WE CARRY A LOT TOM DASCHLE.
IN MY LIFE.
THOUGH I LIVE IN SICK YOU COUNTY
AND Y. RICA.
MY FAVORITE JOB.
THAT I LIKE THAT I HAVE RIGHT
NOW IS THE FIRST ONE I GOT.
WAS A PEER MENTOR.
HELP IN.
WHAT DISABILITIES WITH THEIR
GRIEF?
BECAUSE OTHER PEOPLE THOUGHT
THAT PEOPLE DISABILITIES
ESPECIALLY WHEN YOU WOULD HEAR
MINISTERS PREACH THAT WOULD
DISABLE PEOPLE WHEN THEY DIE
NEVER HAD A LIFE WHEN THEY WERE
ALIVE WHICH IS NOT TRUE.
THAT IS WHY I TOOK ON THE JOB AS
A PEER MENTOR.
I LOVED THAT JOB AND I EVEN
HELPED OVER THE DANCE DIRECTIVES
MY NEXT FAVORITE JOB IF YES I'M
ALSO ON THE STATE TEAM.
AND I LET KIDS KNOW THAT IT IS
NOT BUT TO BE BULLIED AS A
PERSON WITH A DISABILITY AND I'M
THE SAME AS THEY ARE BECAUSE I
CAN DO WHAT THEY CAN.
AND I LET HIM KNOW THAT WHEN I
GO FROM SCHOOLS THE SCHOOLS ARE.
OPPORTUNITY CENTERS.
MY OTHER JOB IF I'M A PATHFINDER.
AND AS A PATHFINDER LIFE GUIDE I
TEACH.
PEOPLE DISABILITIES THAT THEY
TOO COULD HAVE DREAMS AND WE PUT
A BOOK TOGETHER AND WE LET THEM
KNOW THAT THEY HAVE THESE DREAMS
OF DAY TO COULD REACH.
AND I AM THE PROOF OF THOSE
DREAMS CAN BE REACHED.
AND I'M ALSO ON THE POOR
NORTHERN REGIONAL CENTER BOARD.
AGAIN I AM THE ONE OF THE
BIGGEST PROOF OF EXPERIENCE IS
NOT ALL TALK.
THAT PEOPLE DISABILITIES CAN'T
DO THE THINGS.
BUT WHAT'S THE PROBLEM BECAUSE
OF THESE.
WELL IT IS REALLY HARD. TO DO
THIS STUFF.
BECAUSE MINIMUM WAGES YOU KNOW
KEEPS GOING UP AND UP AND UP.
AND I HAVE TO IT REMIND YOU
THERE ARE.
THAT.
WE'RE NOT THE SAME AS EVERYBODY
ELSE IT GETS THE JOB BECAUSE
WERE ON THIS SIDE OF THE
CONFLICT LAW THAT WE CAN'T
CHANGE AND THAT IS IF YOU MAKE
MONEY.
WE HAVE TO TAKE SO MUCH AWAY
WELL THAT DOESN'T HELP US AND
EVEN THOUGH I'M ON LOW INCOME
HOUSING THANK GOD BUT ALONG WITH
THAT.
THE PROPANE I HAVE TO PAID Y.
RICA THANK GOD THERE IS A
DISCOUNT WAS PUT A DISCOUNT I
WOULDN'T BE ABLE TO LIVE AND WHY
WE COULD CALIFORNIA BUT THAT
STILL DOESN'T SOLVE THE PROBLEM
BECAUSE THE MANAGER STILL.
GOES BY.
MY NOT ONLY MY AS A SIDE BUT
THEY ALSO GO BY WHAT I'D MAKE IT
WE CARE A LOT.
I CAN'T MAKE A LOT.
AND ONE OF MY OTHER BIGGEST
THINGS OF EVEN IF I WANTED TO
HELP.
THERE'S A LOT OF PEOPLE THAT
CAN'T HELP BECAUSE THEY DON'T
AND I'VE HAD THE EXPERIENCE THAT
WHEN I WAS A PART OF A PROGRAM.
THAT THE STAFF KEPT CHANGING AND
CHANGING. FOR WHATEVER REASON
AND AND AND WHAT WE HAVE TO
REMEMBER IS PEOPLE DISABILITIES
CAN HANDLE THAT AND I WAS ONE OF
THE CAN'T HANDLE THAT.
AND WE NEED MORE TRAINING LIKE
YOU'VE HEARD ALREADY WE NEED
BETTER PAY WE NEED BETTER STAFF
THAT OUR TRADE AND BE WILLING TO
WANT TO STAY BECAUSE OF DISABLED
PEOPLE NEEDS THAT.
AND THAT'S WHAT IT'S ALL ABOUT
IT'S ABOUT GETTING THAT FUNDING
SO THAT WE CAN SURVIVE.
THANK YOU ANDREAS.
I JUST WANNA BOTTLE YOUR SPIRIT
THANK YOU FOR YOUR
ACCOMPLISHMENTS.
TERRY THANK YOU.
TELL ME TORRENT AND I'M THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF WE CARE A
LOT FOUNDATION.
AND THIS IS A TOUGH ACT TO
FOLLOW.
ARMY JOB IS TO SUPPORT PEOPLE TO
BE ADVOCATES SELF ADVOCACY
YOU'VE HEARD THAT TERM BEFORE IN
OUR AREA THE LIKE THE COLLEGE
ADVOCACY BECAUSE THEY LEARN TO
SPEAK FOR THEMSELVES AS WELL.
AS THEIR PEERS.
THAT THEY'RE ALL IN IT TOGETHER.
SO THAT'S THE MAIN JOB OF WE
CARE A LOT IS THE SPORT ADVOCACY
IN OUR REGION AND WE DO THAT
MAINLY THROUGH PEOPLE FIRST.
WE HAVE CHAPTERS ALL OVER THE
NORTH STATE.
THEN WE HAVE ELEVEN PROGRAMS
WHERE ALL OF THE EMPLOYEE PEOPLE
WITH DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES
TO BE PARENTS STRUCTURES LIFE
KITES.
GRIEF MENTORS SO ALL THE SKILLS
THEY'VE LEARNED IN ADVOCATING
FOR THEMSELVES AND THREE PEOPLE
FIRST ARE.
THEY CAN BRING TO THESE JOBS
YEAH.
THEY WERE USUALLY PEOPLE LIKE ME
WERE IN THE BACKGROUND -- WE'RE
NOT THE SPEAKERS THEY'RE THE
ONES THAT FRONT DOING ALL THE
HARD WORK.
REDUCE IN THE SO [INAUDIBLE]
YOU SEE.
THEIR PASSION IT'S NOT ONLY
EXTENDS TO THEMSELVES BUT TO
THEIR PEERS AND IN THE COMMUNITY
SO ONE OF THE GREAT THINGS IS.
THAT THEY'VE BEEN ABLE TO GO IN
THE COMMUNITY AND BRING OUR
EMERGENCY PREPAREDNESS TO TO THE
SENIOR CITIZENS. TO OTHER FOLKS.
AND THEN GOING TO SCHOOLS THE
MAIN THING IS LEARNING JUST LIKE
ALL OF YOU HERE THAT WE ARE ALL
PEOPLE FIRST SAME ISSUE IDEA.
AND SEWER HOOK.
ALL OF US ARE HOPING TO BUILD A
BETTER WORLD FOR EVERYONE WITH
THAT MESSAGE OF PEOPLE FIRST.
AND I JUST HAVE TO SAY THAT WE
LIVE IN A VERY INNOVATIVE.
REGION HERE OR A LICENSE BEEN A
WONDERFUL DIRECTOR SHE'S LEAVING
NOW AND SHE'S A VISIONARY AND
THAT'S WHAT WE NEED FROM ALL OF
YOU IS A VISION FOR PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES.
A VISION THAT PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES ARE WORTH BEING
FIND DEAD.
I'M IN CONTINUE.
AND THE PEOPLE WHO SUPPORT THEM
THAT THEIR JOBS.
ARE IMPORTANT.
AND THAT THAT THAT'S REFLECTED
IN THEIR PAY SO THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR BEING HERE THANK YOU I
WILL TELL YOU.
I WILL TELL YOU.
THE THAT WE ARE DOING
LEGISLATION.
BASED ON ADVANCEMENT IN AT WORKS
WERE POSSIBILITIES FOR THE ID
POPULATION WAS TAX CREDITS FOR
EMPLOYERS INTEGRATED WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT TRAINING AFTER LIFE
SKILLS.
SO WE'RE DOING A LOT OF BECAUSE
OF THE INFORMATION THAT WE'VE
CLEANED OUT OF THESE HEARINGS.
THAT.
SHOWS THAT THIS IS THE ABSOLUTE
SUCCESSES SECONDHAND HAVE
OUTCOMES.
GETTING PEOPLE OUT OF GROUP
HOMES AND AND SELF SUSTAINING
IT'S IT'S IT'S JUST A IT IS A
BUSINESS PLAN.
AND WE'RE GONNA BE WORKING ON
THAT VERY HARD IN THE NEXT.
HOPEFULLY SIX YEARS LIKE IF I
REMAIN ELECTED [INAUDIBLE]
BUT THANK YOU FOR THIS AND I'M
GLAD YOU CAME UP LAST IS SO YOU
COULD JUST BE THE ANCHOR FOR
THESE WONDERFUL MEN.
AND HE THINKS THAT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH TO ALL THE
ALL THE ADVOCATES AND REALLY
APPRECIATE WHAT YOU'RE DOING.
THANK YOU ESPECIALLY UNDRESS AT
AGAIN ON A BOTTLE THAT SPIRITS
FANTASTIC THANK YOU.
SO THANK YOU ALL FOR SHARING
YOUR STORIES -- VERY
INSPIRATIONAL.
AND ONE OF THE THINGS WE HAVE AS
WE HAVE MORE PRESENTATIONS
COMING UP.
I DON'T THINK ALL OF YOU.
WHO ARE PRESENT?
OF PRESENTING HERE -- AND BEING
HERE THIS EVENING.
S. KEEP YOUR PRESENTATIONS THE
TIME WATER ON THE ENGINE AS WE
CAN KEEP ON SCHEDULE.
SO NEXT WE'RE GOING TO HEAR
ABOUT SOLUTIONS BY INNOVATION.
EMPLOYMENT FOR REGIONAL CENTER
CLIENTS SO WITH THE INDIVIDUALS
IT'LL BE TO HAVE ALEX
[INAUDIBLE]
MATTHEW [INAUDIBLE]
THERESA.
KRISTIN TONYA RAE OSCAR AND
EMILY.
COME ON UP.
WE'LL START WITH THE ALEX WOKE
AND MEGHAN SKINNER.
HELLO THEY DO -- OUR SCHOOL.
TURN AROUND FROM PLACE.
THERE WE GO MUSICAL CHAIRS AGAIN
THE WE'RE GONNA GET THIS I'M
TELLING YOU BY THE END WILL HAVE
IT.
ALEX PLEASE START THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
OF WHAT'S GONNA BALLOTS WORK ON
THE FINANCIAL MANAGER FOR
LITERATE HAND IN CHICO
CALIFORNIA RIGHT LIVE.
THE COMPANY BEGAN WITH A VISION
FOR MY MOTHER TERESA LOW CASE
AND HER FRIENDS BUT ALSO
CHILDREN WITH DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES.
THEY WANT TO CREATE A WAY TO
HELP SUPPORT THEIR CHILDREN'S
FUTURE.
THEY WERE ABLE TO PARTNER WITH
PARTNER THE REGIONAL CENTER TO
GIVE ADULTS WITH THE DEFENSE OF
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES A
CHANCE TO WORK.
I HAVE BEEN INVOLVED WITH LOWER
AT HAND AS A VOLUNTEER SINCE IT
FIRST OPENED IN.
TWO THOUSAND ONE BUT I DID WORK
FOR A PAYCHECK WHAT IN TWO
THOUSAND EIGHT WHEN I JUST
TURNED.
EIGHTEEN IT MAKES ME HAPPY TO
WORK FOR A COMPANY LIKE THIS
BECAUSE I'M A PART OF SOMETHING
BIGGER.
I AM ABLE TO TRAIN PEOPLE BUT WE
HELP EACH OTHER OUT WORKING AT
LOWER HEN TAUGHT ME TO WORKING
GROUP'S WHICH HELP ME GRADUATED
CHECK A STATE IN TWO THOUSAND
SIXTEEN WITH A BACHELOR'S DEGREE.
IN BUSINESS.
I FELT VERY PROUD -- IN THIS
DEGREE AND PUT IT TO USE WORKING
IN THE FINANCE DEPARTMENT AT
WILL RIGHT HAND.
AS A CHILD I WAS DIAGNOSED WITH
AUTISM AS I GREW MY MOTHER
TERESA REALIZE THERE WEREN'T A
LOT OF PROGRAMS RIGHT SHE GO
CALIFORNIA.
WHERE WE LIVE THAT SUPPORTED
PEOPLE WITH ABOUT MENTAL
DISABILITIES SHE BEGAN TO WONDER
WHAT WOULD HAPPEN TO ME?
WHEN I BECOME AN ADULT?
AFTER HAVING SUCCESS RAISING
MONEY BY BRINGING PLANTS THE
LIFE THAT WERE DONATED BY LOCAL
NURSERIES TO PURCHASE COMPUTERS
FOR SEVERELY HANDICAPPED
CHILDREN'S CLASSROOMS.
SHE REALIZED SHE COULD CREATE A
BUSINESS THAT COULD GROW INTO A
SUPPORT SYSTEM WITH PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES.
SHE WAS ABLE TO START HER OWN
NONPROFIT YOUR PICK WINNERS
THREE LITTLE AHEAD NURSERY IN
TWO THOUSAND ONE BY PARDONING
WITH FAR NORTHERN REGIONAL
CENTER.
AND TO HELP FILL THE GAPS IN
SERVICES SHE SUFFERED
DEVELOPMENTALLY DISABLED ADULTS.
THE PLANT NURSERY CREATED
SUPPORT OF EMPLOYMENT BY HIRING
BUREAU TYPICAL INSTRUCTORS WHO
WORKED WITH DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES THE STAFF MEMBERS
TEACH THEM HOW TO CARE FOR
PLANTS IN EACH OTHER.
AS DEVELOPMENTALLY DISABLED
PEOPLE WITH DIFFERENT NEEDS AND
SKILLS JOINED THE COMPANY THE
COMPANY GREW TO SUPPORT THEIR
NEEDS BY OPENING UP NEW VARIOUS
LOCATIONS.
FOLLOWING THE SAME SUPPORTED
EMPLOYMENT MODEL SILVER USE
LATER THE LITTLE RED HEN GIFT
SHOP OPEN TO SERVICE STAFF WHO
NEEDED TO WORK IN A SPACE OF THE
ELEMENTS.
THEN SHE OPENED A KITCHEN STORE
FOLLOWED BY VINTAGE SHOP AND I'M
GOING TO KEEP IT A FULL SERVICE
FLORAL MORE SHOP.
TREES A HAS ALSO CREATED SEVERAL
NON RETAIL DEPARTMENTS TO TO
SUPPORT THE STAFF IN OTHER WAYS.
THE ONLINE DEPARTMENT SUPPORT
STAFF OF COMPUTER SKILLS BY
WORKING IN IN GRAPHIC DESIGN
WEBSITE MAINTENANCE FACILITY
BEING IN AN ECONOMIST STORE AND
SOCIAL MEDIA LIKE FACEBOOK AND
MYSPACE.
SHE ALSO CREATE A GREENHOUSE AND
PROPAGATED XIN DEPARTMENT IN A
TOOLS AND TRADE DEPARTMENT WE'RE
STAFF LEARN BUILDING AND
MECHANICAL SKILLS.
AFTER DONATION OF LAND WITH FROM
A LOCAL BUSINESS WAS GIVEN TO US
LITERACY AND PARKING GARDEN WAS
CREATED.
WHICH TEACHERS STAFF ABOUT
GARDENING INCLUDING THE CARE
FREE RANGE CHICKENS AND THE
IMPORTANCE OF HEALTH THE LOCAL
GROWN PRODUCE AND EDUCATE ABOUT
NUTRIENTS EATING CHOICES WHICH
IS VERY IMPORTANT.
EVERY LOCATION IN PLACE ADULTS
WITH DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES
AT A COMPETITIVE WAGE BECAUSE WE
BELIEVE THAT EVERYONE SHOULD
HAVE TO WORK IN AN OPPORTUNITY
TO WORK AND BE PAID FOR THE JOB
THAT THEY DO.
PART OF OUR MISSION IS TO
EDUCATE THE COMMUNITY ABOUT THE
VALUE OF ADULTS WITH
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES AND
THAT WHAT MATTERS IS OUR
ABILITIES NOT OUR IN OUR IN
ABILITIES.
WE ALSO RUN THE RIGHT HAND Y.
SPENCER WHICH SERVICES OVER A
HUNDRED CHILDREN A WEEK OR ON
THE AUTISM SPECTRUM.
THROUGH WEEKLY PROGRAM SUCH AS
OUR SUMMER THEATER PROGRAM IN
OUR FLOCK SOCIALIZATION PROGRAM.
OUR LOCATION EMPLOYS OVER A
HUNDRED THIRTY FIVE ADULTS WITH
DISABILITIES AND WE HAVE A
WAITING LIST FOR MORE PEOPLE WHO
WANT TO WORK WITH US BECAUSE OF
WHAT THEY HEARD ABOUT US.
PROGRAMS LIKE OURS ARE IMPORTANT
TO THE COMMUNITY AND ESPECIALLY
TO PEOPLE LIKE ME WHO ARE ABLE
TO SUCCEED THANKS TO SUPPORT
FROM WILL READ HAND AND PARTNER
THE REGIONAL CENTER AND OTHER
PEOPLE THAT.
ARE IN THAT AREA.
AND NOW I WOULD LIKE TO
INTRODUCE MAKE IN WHO WORKS IN
OUR GIFT SHOP IN OUR ONLINE
DEPARTMENT.
WHO WILL TALK ABOUT WHAT SHE
DOES AND THE BENEFITS SHE
RECEIVED AS AN EMPLOYEE AT
LITERATE HIM WITH US?
THANK YOU ALEX [INAUDIBLE]
HELLO.
THOSE WHO DON'T.
SINGLE YEP IS ON ALONE.
THOSE WHO DON'T KNOW ME.
HI.
MY NAME IS MEGAN HE'S GONNA.
AND I WORK FOR A LITTLE OVER TO
HIM.
I HAVE BEEN WORKING FOR A LITTLE
BIT HIM FOR OVER TWELVE YEARS.
NO.
I STARTED WORKING FOR THE LITTLE
RED HEN.
BACK IN MARCH OF TWO THOUSAND
AND SEVEN I STARTED WORKING OUT.
TO PLANT NURSERY.
I STARTED OUT THREE HOURS A WEEK
IN LONDON IN THE ROCK WAS
CUSTOMER.
ALTHOUGH IT BECAME MORE
COMFORTABLE.
AND MORE HOURS AND BEGAN WORKING.
AT THE LITTLE RED HEN GIVES UP.
AND THE DATE THAT I STARTED
WORKING NOT TO GIVE STOP WAS
FIGHTING NOVEMBER TWENTY THIRD.
TWO THOUSAND SEVEN AND NINE
O'CLOCK IN THE MORNING.
THEY ALSO THANKSGIVING IN.
TWO THOUSAND SEVEN I HAVE BEEN
ABLE TO WATCH A GOLDEN IS ASIAN
GOAL FROM A PLANT NURSERY.
DIFFERENT PROGRAMS.
I STARTED AS A STOP TWENTY IN
TWO THOUSAND AND SEVEN IN
DECEMBER TWENTY TWELVE AFTER I
LEARNED TO INTERACT WITH.
CUSTOMERS.
WORK INDEPENDENTLY.
AND TEACH OTHERS THAT MOM WAS
HOW TO DO THEIR JOBS CORRECTLY.
I OWN A PROMOTION TO STOP
ASSISTANT.
IN DECEMBER TWENTY FIFTEEN I AM
NOT A PROMOTION THE SENIORS STOP
ASSISTANT.
ONLY THESE PROMOTIONS MADE ME
FEEL ACCOMPLISHED.
I AM PROUD OF MYSELF.
THEY MADE ME FEEL LIKE I CAN DO
ANYTHING.
WHEN I WORKED AT LITTLE ON HIM?
I RECEIVE GUIDANCE AND SUPPORT.
I WAS SLEEVES I WOULD SEE
SUPPORT NO MATTER WHAT THE
CIRCUMSTANCES.
SKILLS I'VE LEARNED UP A LITTLE
BIT IN.
HELP ME TO BECOME MORE.
BE MORE COMFORTABLE TALKING TO
PEOPLE.
FIRSTLY DO YOU GUYS.
HELP ME BECOME A BOZO SELF
PUBLIC IT.
CAN APPEAR ADVOCATE.
THEY ALSO TOLD ME TO USE MY
VOICE.
HE WAS A LITTLE.
GAVE ME THE OPPORTUNITY TO USE
MY VOICE.
KNOWINGLY.
THE ONLY OTHER HUMAN BUT ALSO
ITSELF OF A KIT.
WE ALSO WORK. FOR THE LOW BUDGET
FOOD.
WE KILL OFF FOUNDATION WHICH I
CAN TEACH ADULTS WITH
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES THE
APPOINTMENTS OF VOTING.
I WANT TO TALK MORE ABOUT THE
VALUE OF WORKING FULL LITTLE LET
HIM.
WE CANNOT LIVE WITHIN.
HELP ME AND PHOTO STUFF MEMBERS
LEARN. TO SOCIALIZE.
IN IRAQ WITH THE COMMUNITY.
WE PAID A FAIR WAGE WHICH MAKES
OUR STOP MEMBERS ZERO DIGNIFIED
[INAUDIBLE]
RESPECTED [INAUDIBLE]
VALUED.
I WAS STAFF MEMBERS GETTING MANY.
MANY.
NEW SKILLS THAT THEY CAN USE UP
WORK AS WELL AS IN THE COMMUNITY.
WORKING IN OTHER LOCATIONS HELP
STOP MEMBERS.
FEEL SAFE BECAUSE THOSE ARE SAFE
AND PRODUCTIVE WORK ENVIRONMENT.
EACH OF OUR LOCATIONS IS UNIQUE
AND ALSO TEACHES STEP MOM WAS
MANY DIFFERENT SKILLS.
SOME OF THE DOES THE I GET TO DO.
WORK INCLUDE.
BACK IN JUNE WHICH I LIKE TO
TAKE PHOTOGRAPHS.
MONEY HERE KNOWING HIM MONEY
COUNTING SKILLS.
LITTLE RED HÌNH STARS TO CAN
CONTINUALLY.
TEACHERS STAFF MEMBERS NEW TASK
SO THEY CAN.
GO AS INDIVIDUALS.
MOVIES SO QUALITY POLITICS OUT
OF FIVE RETAIL LOCATIONS WHAT'S
HELP SUPPORT OF PROGRAMS.
WHEN YOU WORK AT LITTLE WITHIN
THE UP TO FEEL MORE ORGANIC?
IN VALUE DOES A HUMAN BEING.
HELPS DEVELOP LIFE SKILLS WORK
AND ALSO IN.
PUBLIC PLACES.
ALSO LITTLE RED HEN MAKES YOU
FEEL MORE.
AT HOME.
THEY'RE NOT WORK BECAUSE YOU
HAVE ITEMS.
IN WHICH A VIBRANT COLORS.
IN SOME REALLY SOOTHING COLORS.
THE PROJECT HE'S WHEN YOU COME
INTO WORK SO.
YOU DON'T FEEL AS ANXIOUS.
WE ALSO HAVE A IN THE AMOUNT OF
PRODUCT OF YOU ONE FROM ALL
WALKS OF LIFE.
I WANT TO THANK FOR NO OTHER
REASON ALSO.
NINE AND WONDERFUL COMMUNITY FOR
ALL THE SUPPORT WHICH KEEPS THE
LITTLE RED HEN GOING.
I ALSO I ALSO WANT TO THANK MY
SUPPORT SYSTEM FOR BEING BEHIND
ME ALL THOSE YEARS INCLUDING
LIFE.
INCLUDING MY FAMILY.
MY FRIENDS YEAH MY COLLEAGUES.
I WOULD NOT BE HERE IF IT HASN'T
IF I HAVE BEEN FOR YOU GUYS SO
THANK YOU GUYS.
I ALSO WANT TO THINK NOT TO ME.
PHONE FOUR NORTHERN REGIONAL
CENTER EVEN THOUGH SHE'S NO
LONGER WITH US.
I WANT TO THANK HER FROM.
FULL OFFERS SUPPORT IN HELPING
ME TO GET A JOB BUT LITTLE RED
HAND.
HIM FOR NORTHERN.
MAY SHE REST IN PEACE.
IN THE NAME OF THE FATHER.
AND THE SON AND THE HOLY SPIRIT
AMEN.
IN ALSO LASTLY I WANT TO THANK
IN.
EVERY EACH AND EVERYONE OF YOU
SO MUCH FOR YOUR TIME.
AND ONLY HOPE USE I HOPE TO SEE
YOU GUYS VERY VERY SOON THANK
YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU MAY.
SO MILLION -- HOLD ON THE
MICROPHONE PER SECOND -- MAKE
ANY SKINNER WAS THE STAND.
FOR THIS IS MY MIDDLE NAME IT'S
THIS PLAN ALSO HAS ALWAYS BEEN.
YEAH SO I WANT TO LET YOU KNOW --
THAT.
YOUR COLLEAGUE SITTING NEXT TO
ALEX WAS BEING AS BRIGHT AS THE
MOON AS PROUD AS HE IS OF YOU SO
YOU'RE WONDERFUL JOB THANK YOU.
TO MOVE ON TO MATTHEW FUENTES.
HELLO MY NAME IS MATTHEW DIDN'T
WANT DOES I AM -- AUTISTIC.
AND I'VE BEEN WORKING WITH G.
CITY FITNESS PER.
WELL SINCE AUGUST OF TWENTY
FIFTEEN WHERE I CAME FROM I WAS
BORN IN -- IN THE BAY AREA AND
THEN I CAME UP LIVING WITH MY
GRANDPARENTS AND ONCE I WAS
ABOUT TO MY PARENTS GOT A
DIVORCE WHEN I WAS A BABY.
GOING THROUGH SCHOOL IT WAS HARD
TO MAKE HARD TO MAKE FRIENDS
[INAUDIBLE]
AND I WILL ALWAYS HI MY HI MY
FACE FROM -- FROM A YEP HI FROM
SCHOOL MATES.
IS -- WHAT I WOULD DO I WOULD
TALK MYSELF ROOM FROM MOVIES?
AND THEN -- IN HIGH SCHOOL I WAS
A A I WAS A FOOTBALL PLAYER ONLY
MY FRESHMAN YEAR BUT THEN I QUIT
BECAUSE MY EXACT EIGHTY I COULD
A MINUTE BECAUSE I WAS AFRAID I
WAS GONNA MAKE FUN OF BUT BUT I
HAD GOOD EDUCATION GOING THROUGH
A SPECIAL EDUCATION.
AND INTO A HIGH SCHOOL I
GRADUATED WITH THE DIPLOMA.
THEN AFTER THAT -- WHAT GOT ME
FROM A?
BEEN A WHO I AM TODAY -- I WAS --
I WAS A MENTOR [INAUDIBLE] FOR
FOR FOR REBELS GET SET OR SLATE.
WHICH IS A A A PROGRAM FOR
STUDENTS WITH AUTISM.
AND THEN -- AFTER THAT WELL.
ABOUT THE UP MOST OF THE TIMES I
SIT MY **** ALL DAY PLAYING
VIDEO GAMES THAT'S MY IT'S A
HARD ADDICTION -- TO GET AWAY
FROM IT'S UNFORTUNATE.
YEAH MY GRANDPARENTS ALWAYS
WORRIED ABOUT ME.
MATH LIKE.
MATTHEW WHAT IS SUPPOSED TO DO A
LIVE ON YOUR OWN MATTHEW HOW ARE
YOU SUPPOSED TO WORK.
SO I WENT THROUGH A COUPLE DAY
PROGRAMS -- I WAS A I'M AN
ARTIST I WENT THROUGH A WINDOW
ARTISTIC ENDEAVORS.
IT'S THE ART PLACE FOR A IN ANY
WAY WITH DISABILITIES WHO WHO
KNOWS HOW TO DO ART HOW -- TO
MAKE MONEY [INAUDIBLE]
WHEN OUR [INAUDIBLE]
THEN I'M.
AFTER THAT THEN I WENT ON TO A
CP WHICH IS -- CREATIVE.
CREATIVE POSITIVE ENVIRONMENT.
KIND OF IT'S A BEHAVIORAL
PROGRAM WHERE THEY TEACH PEOPLE
HOW -- TO HOW TO DO JOBS HOW TO
MAKE MONEY.
WELL WE DON'T THEY WE DELIVERED
FOOD.
YEAH AND BECAUSE OF THE
BEHAVIORS EVER GOING ON IN THE
IN THE PROGRAM -- I FELT
UNCOMFORTABLE BEING THERE
BECAUSE I'M NOT.
I'M NOT LIKE -- I DON'T KNOW HOW
TO DESCRIBE OTHERS PRIVATE LIKE
A LOW FUNCTIONAL AT THAT
BEHAVIOR IS I'M NOT I'M NOT
THOSE.
NO WHAT.
AM I GONNA STAY IN A A PROGRAM
FOR THE REST OF MY LIFE THEN UP
COMES A G. CITY FITNESS.
IN THE WHERE IT'S NOT A DAY
PROGRAM IT'S AN ACTUAL JOB.
IF A REAL JOB.
SO WHAT I SO WHAT I'VE DONE
SUCCESSOR IN THROUGH -- SHE'S
EVEN IS IS THAT I'M A A A
CERTIFIED PERSONAL TRAINER
[INAUDIBLE]
IN.
I TOUCH I EVEN TRAIN NEW STAFF
SINCE I'VE HAD PLENTY OF
EXPERIENCES AT G. CITY.
AND I PARTICIPATED IN -- MISTER
ROGERS EVENT [INAUDIBLE]
I I TESTED MY SKILLS VERY GOOD
LEE AT THE MUD RUN [INAUDIBLE]
AND ALSO.
IT WILL THE KNOWN LEARN HOW --
TO TO HOW TO DEVELOP SKILLS A
BLOOM I OWN WORKING ON MY OWN
WITHOUT SUPERVISION.
AND ALSO LATELY I'VE BEEN DOING
SOME PUBLIC SPEAKING
[INAUDIBLE]
ON A INSPIRING PEOPLE HOW HOW DO
A LIVE THE REALIZED HOW HOW I
LIVED THROUGH MINE.
AND I'M SUPPOSED TO HELP ONE
NEXT THURSDAY AT THE MOTOR
ACCOUNTING AT THE RHONDA HAS
SOME.
INVITATION THAT'S JUST A
SHAMELESS PLUG.
JUST SAYING.
YEAH.
SO THAT'S THE STORY ABOUT ME ON
HOW A GO THROUGH PROGRESS AND IF
IT WASN'T FOR A LISTEN SHIPS IN
DC HAVE BEEN AS I WOULDN'T I
WOULDN'T BE WHERE I AM TODAY.
WELL YOU KNOW WHAT WE'RE VERY
PROUD OF YOU AND AND THANK YOU
FOR SHARING YOUR STORY WILL MOVE
ON TO THE NEXT PERSON.
OUR BOSS MELISSA SHIPS LISTEN
YES [INAUDIBLE]
HELLO.
I WASN'T ON THE LIST FOR SOME
ODD REASON -- AND I WON'T TAKE
TOO MUCH OF YOUR TIME I JUST
WANTED TO EXPLAIN IF YOU'RE
WONDERING.
ABOUT DO YOU CITY FITNESS -- DC
BUSINESS STANDS FOR GROW CHANGE
AND DEVELOP -- IT IS A FULL
FUNCTIONING GYM AND FITNESS
STUDIO -- WE'VE BEEN OPERATING
SINCE AUGUST OF TWO THOUSAND AND
FIFTEEN WE SERVE ROUGHLY AROUND
FIVE HUNDRED MEMBERS WE ARE OPEN
TO THE PUBLIC AND WE EMPLOY
THOSE WITH AND WITHOUT
INTELLECTUAL AND DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES -- THEY PERFORM
TASKS ANYWHERE FROM PERSONAL
TRAINING -- TO JUST THE REGULAR
MONDAY IN BUSINESS -- TASKS SUCH
AS RUNNING REGISTER BALANCING
CASH REGISTER -- AND CLEANINGS
GENERAL SANITATION DUTIES WE DO
A LOT OF PUBLIC EVENTS WHERE WE
LIKE TO GET INVOLVED IN THE
COMMUNITY -- SOME OF THE FUN
THINGS THAT WE DO LIKE MATTHEW
IT MENTIONED WAS THE THE SHASTA
MUD RUN SO WE DO THAT WE GET TO
WEAR LOGO'S AND AND GET OUT AND
YOU KNOW REALLY REACH OUT TO OUR
COMMUNITY WE WE HAVE -- WE'VE
DONE THE MISTER ROGERS EVENTS
AND HEALTH FAIRS AND THINGS LIKE
THAT AND WE DO FUNDS SOCIAL
MEDIA POSTS CAM SILLY THINGS
WILL WORK WORK SO.
WE LIKE TO YOU KNOW REALLY LIKE
TO PROMOTE HEALTH AND WELLNESS
WILL HAVING FUN AT THE SAME TIME
SO IT REALLY IS A GREAT PROGRAM.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
FOR SUPPORTING THE IDEA
POPULATION [INAUDIBLE]
THERESA.
I WORK FOR A HAND JAM.
AND WHAT I AM STANDS FOR IS.
H. STAND FOR A ANTHONY EM
STAMPER MICHAEL.
I CAN'T FOR JOE.
TO IN CAN'T REMEMBER SHALL IT BE
IN BEAT AND REMAND THOSE ARE A
CO DIRECTORS KID.
DAY I BOUGHT IT.
NORTH STATE.
REGION RESTORED HIGHLIGHT BY
TREES TO MODE.
DO YOU.
DO YOU EVER NEED SOMEONE TO TALK
TO OR CHIU OR JEWS YOU FORGET TO
TAKE YOUR MEDICATION.
DO YOU LIVE ALONE EDWARD
SOMEWHERE DO YOU CHECK IN WITH
YOU.
ARE YOU CONCERNED ABOUT A LEVEL
I HAD THE ANSWER FOR YOU.
THE ACTOR THE CALL CONNECTION
CALL CONNECTION.
IS A THREE DIGIT RICH MA'AM CAM
BEYOND COULD INCLUDE YOUR I'M AN
EMPLOYEE OF THE CALL YES I LOVE
CALLING PEOPLE AND HELPING THEM.
WITH WHAT THEY NEED.
IT'S A GREAT JOB I WORK MORE OUR
DO YOU TWEET THE CALL CONNECTION.
STARTED IN TWO THOUSAND THIRTEEN
YEAH APPROX EMPLOYED TO PARK
MEAT THIRTY PEOPLE WHO WORK GET
RICH SHIPPED ABOUT THE WE WE ALL
OR MINIMAL WEIGHT IT GO I DATE.
MY HEAD WITHOUT A JOB THERE.
TOO WELL IT MIGHT BE AS FREE
AGENTS.
THANK YOU YOU WILL BE LEAVING.
THE DRAWS.
YOUR DOOR MOVING OUT OF STATE
THE COLORADO.
WE ALL HAVE ASSIGNMENTS.
PEOPLE WE CALL INDIVIDUAL
PROTOCOL IS FOLLOWED.
HEIDI SHE DID A WONDERFUL BOUGHT
IF YOU WANT TO KNOW MORE ABOUT
THIS FEATURE RICH.
THE WEB W. W. W. W. DOT AM CAM
DOT COM AND THEIR PHONE NUMBERS
FIVE OO EIGHT SEVEN TWO EIGHT
PIPE TO CHECK.
AND WE ARE NO LONGER.
LOCATED IN PARADISE DUE TO THE
CAMPFIRE.
WE NOW OF IT IS -- OPERATIVE
CHICO AT ON A WONDER THERE'S A
BUYER WORKED UP THE CAMPFIRE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR
PRESENTATION.
SO WHAT WE'RE GONNA DO AND AGAIN
VERY PROUD OF YOU AND THANK YOU.
FOR FIND OUT IF YOU WANT.
WE WILL GET SOME FROM YOU SO
WHAT I WOULD HAVE TO DO IS MAKE
A LITTLE SPACE FOR OUR NEXT
PRESENTER SO EVERYBODY HAS BEEN
UP IT TO THE TABLE THANK YOU SO
VERY MUCH FOR BEING HERE -- I
HAVE ON MY AGENDA NOR CAL PATHS.
AND FOR OUR TONY TANYA RAE OSCAR
VALDEZ NOW THIS AND AND WE
WELCOME [INAUDIBLE]
AND YOUR GETTING READY HERE.
SANDRA -- IF YOU COULD MOVE THE
EASEL OVER ABOUT THREE FEET.
THAT IS ALL THIS WAY SO THAT WE
CAN SEE THE FOLKS.
PLEASE.
PERFECT THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
WE DON'T LIKE TO GO IN THE ORDER
THAT YOU PREFER TO GO IN JUST
PLEASE -- STATION AM HERE
REPRESENTING AND FORGERS.
MY NAME IS KRISTEN FOR ON THE
OWNER OF NOR CUP AT SERVICES --
WE'VE BEEN OPEN ABOUT THREE
YEARS WE PROVIDE EMPLOYMENT TO
FOLKS WITH DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES.
WE HAVE NOT ONLY -- THAT HAVE NO
DISABILITIES BUT THEN ALSO WE
HIRE FOLKS THAT HAVE
DISABILITIES.
I WE BROUGHT TO WITH US SO THEY
CAN SHARE THEIR EXPERIENCE
WORKING THERE -- WE BROUGHT YOU
GUYS A COUPLE THINGS THAT WILL
SHOW YOU THE PICTURES UP THERE
SHOWS SOME OF OUR OFFENSE THAT
WE DO WE ARE INVOLVED WITH --
HAVEN HUMANE WE DO PET FAST WE
DO IT IN THE HOUSE TO DO WITH
ANIMALS WERE THERE -- SUPPORTING
ANIMALS GETTING OUR
ADVERTISEMENT OUT.
WE DO PAT BOARDING WE DO --
BOARDING GROOMING SERVICES AND
DOGGY DAY CARE WE HAVE A FORTY
FIVE HUNDRED SQUARE FOOT
BUILDING.
AS HUGE THERE'S A A LOT OF WORK
TO DO -- OUR OUR CLIENTS WORK
VERY VERY HARD IT'S NOT
NECESSARILY WE DON'T CONSIDERED
A PROGRAM OR ANYTHING OF THE
SORT WE DEFINITELY CONSIDER IT
TO BE COMMUNITY INTEGRATION.
THEY DO GET PAID MINIMUM WAGE
THEY'RE ACTUALLY GETTING PAID
ALMOST THE SAME AS THE STAFF --
THEY WORK SIX HOURS A DAY THEY
HAVE TO TAKE REQUIRED BREAKS
JUST LIKE THE LABOR BOARD
REQUIRES.
AND THEY HAVE TO WORK REALLY
HARD SO -- LET THEM SHARE WITH
YOU -- ABOUT THEIR EXPERIENCE.
THIS IS TONYA REYES SHE'S THE
MANAGER THERE.
HI THANK YOU ALSO MAY FIND THEM
AND THE PROGRAM DIRECTOR NOR CAL
PET SERVICES AND WHAT I ACTUALLY
WANT TO TALK ABOUT WAS AND SOME --
BARRIERS TO SUCCESS -- THAT
WE'VE DEFINITELY NOTICED BEING
OPERATION FOR THE LAST FEW YEARS --
MOST DEFINITELY TRANSPORTATION
FOR THE CONSUMERS GETTING BACK
AND FORTH TO WORK WE HAVE A LOT
OF ISSUES WITH US SO EVEN WITH
ALREADY RIGHT PROGRAM AND THAT'S
A LOT OF KING SAID -- HAD A
QUITE BEEN WORKED OUT AND IT'S
REALLY HAS CREATED SAM I'M SOME
ISSUES EMPLOYMENT FOR SOME OF
OUR CONSUMERS MANY OF OUR
CONSUMERS USE THIS SERVICE -- SO
WE'RE REALLY HOPING TO BE ABLE
TO SEE SOME CHANGES THERE THAT
ARE NOT GOING TO BE BENEFICIAL
FOR EVERYONE [INAUDIBLE]
SO [INAUDIBLE]
ALSO.
WE'VE NOTICED OF IT BEING A TWO
DIFFERENT PROGRAMS AND ONE SO
YOU KNOW WERE FUNCTIONING IN
BUSINESS THAT SERVES THE
COMMUNITY BEFORE ALSO.
A COMMUNITY INTEGRATED TRAINING
PROGRAM AFFORD THESE ADULTS WITH
DISABILITIES.
FUNDING DEFINITELY IS -- A HARD
HIT AT TIMES.
WE HAVE.
THE WAY OUR RACE YOUR WORDS AS
YOU KNOW WE HAVE -- YOU KNOW
THREE CONSUMERS OF ONE STAFF AND
YOU KNOW WE GET WE GET FUNDED
FOR ALL OF THOSE WAGES BUT MANY
TIMES NOW WE WE HAVE BEEN -- BUT
WE'RE GRATEFUL WE'VE BEEN SO
SUCCESSFUL AND NO YOU KNOW AND
OUR MARKETING AND BUILDING A
CUSTOMER BASE AND SERVING THE
COMMUNITY OF THAT.
OUR STAFF HAVE TO WORK MANY MORE
HOURS AND YOU KNOW THEN THE
CONSUMERS AND SO.
WHEN YOU REALLY BREAK DOWN THE
COST AND WHAT THE FUNDING IS
THAT WERE YOU KNOW WE WE DON'T
REALLY COME OUT AHEAD -- SO THAT
I MEAN IN ORDER FOR IT TO BE A
FUNCTIONING SUCCESSFUL BUSINESS
I MEAN IT'S AN INCREASE IN
FUNDING.
DEFINITELY.
WOULD BE HELPFUL -- SO LIKE FOR
INSTANCE OUR OUR NIGHT STAFF
LIKE A VERY AND ALL OF THAT
COMES OUT OF POCKET EVEN IF WE
HAVE YOU KNOW THIRTY DOGS THAT
ARE BOARDING.
ALL OTHER WAGES ARE PAID RIGHT
OUT OF POCKET SO EVERYTHING THAT
WE MADE FOR THAT ONE NIGHT IS
COMPLETELY GONE -- SO AND IT
REALLY PUTS A KINK IN THE WAY
THAT WE CAN OPERATE A BUSINESS
AND THE SERVICES THAT WE CAN
OFFER AS FAR AS ADDITIONAL
TRAINING -- JOBS REAL JOB SKILLS
TRAINING AS FAR AS MONEY
MANAGEMENT AND A LEARNING
RECESSION SKILLS AND COMMUNITY
OUTREACH AND INTERACTING WITH
THE COMMUNITY -- BECAUSE WE RUN
SHORT STAFFED ALL THE TIME.
AND THAT'S NOT JUST -- I THE
SUPERVISORS TO STAFF MEMBERS
THAT ARE YOU KNOW THAT THEIR
DRESS FOR PROFESSIONALS BUT ALSO
WE RUN SHORT WHEN IT COMES TO
CONSUMERS.
AND BECAUSE IT IS KIND OF A A
MORE DIFFICULT JOB.
OF AND NOT EVERYBODY IS.
ABLE TO PARTICIPATE OR IT
COMPLETE THE JOB DUTIES SO.
BUT THE GREAT THING IS IS THAT
WE OFFER A LOT OF ROOM FOR
GROWTH SO WHO WE HAVE HERE WITH
US TODAY AND IS EMILY.
AND OSCAR.
SO -- OSCAR IS ACTUALLY OUR
SECOND CONSUMER THAT WE'VE HIRED
ON AND WE ARE NOW PROMOTING TO A
STAFF MEMBER SO HE'S GONNA BE
WORKING THE FLOOR AS A STAFF
MEMBER.
AND TO PROVIDE A SUPPORT TO
OTHER CONSUMERS AND EMILY IS ONE
OF OUR VERY HARDEST WORKER SHE'S
AMAZING.
AND SHE HAS JUST MADE HER WAY UP
TO A TEAM LEAD WHICH IS THERE TO
SUPPORT BOTH OUR SUPERVISORS ARE
STAFF MEMBERS AND ALSO HER PEERS.
SO I'M.
REALLY NURTURING LEADERS OF
SOMETHING THAT THAT WE HAVE LIKE
SPEND A LOT OF TIME DOING -- AND
PROVIDE IN THAT ROOM FOR GROWTH
AND AND SO THERE'S DEFINITELY
GETS BETTER EVERY DAY -- BUT AS
FAR AS YOU BEING ABLE TO BE
COMPLETELY SUCCESSFUL AND OFFER
EVERYTHING THAT WE WANT TO OFFER
A PET SERVICES.
AND OF A FUNDING AN INCREASE IN
FUNDING.
DEFINITELY.
WOULD HELP [INAUDIBLE]
AND LIKE.
WELCOME EMILY.
THANK YOU -- LET ME JUST SAY
THAT NORTH HEALTH SERVICES HAS
REALLY CHANGED MY LIFE -- THIS
WOULD BE MY FIRST JOB THAT I'VE
EVER HAD -- AND LEARNING HOW IT
ALL KIND OF WORKS IN THE WORK IN
THE IN THE WORK FORCE -- IT'S
ABSOLUTELY AMAZING -- I ACTUALLY
HAVE MY OWN DOG SITTING BUSINESS
THAT I'VE BEEN DOING FOR FOUR
YEARS ON MY OWN -- WITH MY
FAMILY'S HELP HERE AND THERE IF
I NEED HAVE A QUESTION OR
WHATEVER BUT I GET THERE ON MY
OWN AND INDEPENDENT WITH THAT --
BUT WITH THAT SERVICE IS JUST.
YOU KNOW -- THE CO WORKERS AND
THE STAFF MEMBERS.
HAVE BEEN JUST ABSOLUTELY
AMAZING AND THEY'RE JUST THEY'RE
FUN TO GET TO KNOW -- BUT
WORKING WITH THE DOGS AND MAKING
A DIFFERENCE IN THEIR LIVES IS A
REALLY HUGE -- I AM ALSO DOING
I'VE AND PLANNING AND ALSO
ATTEND.
DIFFERENT EVENTS THAT THEY RUN.
AND IT'S JUST A HUGE OPPORTUNITY
TO REACH OUT TO THE COMMUNITY
AND TO GET TO KNOW THE CUSTOMERS
AND FREE TO CUT FUTURE CUSTOMERS
AND JUST IT'S A GREAT
OPPORTUNITY.
PERFECT THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
CLUSTER.
HELLO -- OSCAR -- I'VE BEEN
WORKING AT NORTH KALPETTA
SERVICES FOR A YEAR GETTING
CLOSE TO TWO AND IT'S A GREAT
OPPORTUNITY -- STARTING FROM --
AS A CLIENT JUST WORKING THEIR
LEARNING THE ROPES -- FROM
PROGRESSING TO BE -- A TEAM LEAD.
AND SHOWING OTHER PEOPLE THAT IF
I CAN DO IT THEY CAN DO IT
[INAUDIBLE]
TOO AND LEARNED A LOT FROM --
JUST FROM STAFF -- EVERYONE THAT
WORKS THERE -- A SOMETIMES IT
CAN BE -- SUPER BUSY AND
SOMETIMES HECTIC BUT WE ALWAYS
GET THROUGH -- IT'S IT'S A FUN
JOB -- I LOVE WORKING WITH PETS --
AND THE OPPORTUNITY OF BECOMING --
OF SUPERVISORS -- IT'S IT'S
GREAT AND I JUST WANNA LET
EVERYONE KNOW THAT FOR A PERSON
THAT HAS DISABILITIES IF.
IF I CAN WORK FROM THE BOTTOM
AND GET TO THE TOP ANYONE ELSE
CAN DO IT SO.
YEAH GOOD FOR YOU.
I WILL TELL YOU ARE CERTAINLY
THERE ARE TIMES.
THAT IN MY ROLE I WOULD TRADE
WITH YOU IN A SECOND.
NO YEAH THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PRESENTATION EACH AND EVERYONE
OF YOU AND AND WELL.
WE'LL CONNECT GREAT JOB.
THANK YOU TO KNOW WE'RE GONNA
MOVE ON DID YOU MEAN.
DELEGATION THANK YOU -- NOW WE
MOVE ON TO GOING TO HEAR ABOUT
THE TRANSPORTATION EXPERIMENTS
WITH A GROUP COMING UP -- AND
SOLDIER AND JOSH WELL AND KRISTA
ENSLEY
.
I'M SURE YOU GUYS HAVE YOUR
PLACE HOLDERS WOULD WHO'S GOING
FOR SO PLEASE JUST STATE YOUR
NAME AGAIN WE REPRESENT.
I MEAN I'M STILL TURN AYE
MANSELL SERVICES AND I'M TALKING
TO YOU ABOUT THE BUS GREAT
PROGRAM THAT'S IN BUTTE COUNTY
[INAUDIBLE]
SORRY.
IT DOESN'T MATTER [INAUDIBLE]
THANKS.
SO I THINK THIS IS A GREAT
REPRESENTATION OF INNOVATION
CREATIVITY AND OUR STATE JUST
FIGURING THINGS OUT.
I AM WE STARTED IN.
TWO THOUSAND ELEVEN AND WE
PAIRED WITH THE PUBLIC
TRANSPORTATION AGENCY AND BUTTE
COUNTY CALLED THE BEE LINE --
FAR NORTHERN REGIONAL CENTER AND
THEN MANSELL.
AND WE CAME UP WITH SOME GOALS
THAT WE HAD WHICH WAS INCREASE
WRITER TRANSPORTATION.
INCREASE INDEPENDENCE FOR PEOPLE.
AND THEN CREATE EMPLOYMENT.
OVER THE YEARS WE HAVE SEVEN BUS
GOODS THAT WORK FOR US -- THEY
TRAIN THEIR PEERS ON THE PUBLIC
TRANSPORTATION.
I'M NOT ONLY DO THEY TRAIN THEIR
PEERS THEY NOW GOING TO HIGH
SCHOOLS TO TRAIN CHILDREN ON THE
PUBLIC TRANSPORTATION.
THEY NOW ARE REACHING OUT TO
SENIORS TO INCREASE
TRANSPORTATION AND IT'S REALLY
JUST MORE OFTEN TO THE OUR
COMMUNITY.
ALLIES EVERYBODY THAT KNOWS I'M
IN TOWN THEY WERE THE BEST I. T.
SHIRTS EVERYWHERE SO IF YOU EVER
GO TO CHICO.
YOU'LL SEE THE BASS GUIDES ASKED
ME FOR HELP.
AND THEY WILL KNOW WHAT THE
WHOLE MAP IN WILL RIDE THE BUS
WITH THEM.
I'M SO I JUST THINK IT'S A GREAT
REPRESENTATION OF WHAT FAR
NORTHERN STEWING HERE WITH
CREATIVITY AND INNOVATION AND
THE RIGHT PEOPLE AND PARTNERS.
AND I'M INTRODUCED ASTRA
[INAUDIBLE]
NEXT TIME [INAUDIBLE]
YEAH.
GOOD EVENING MY NAME IS JOSH
WHAT ISLAND I REPRESENT -- FIRST
TRANSIT READY RIGHT WHICH IS ON
ON DEMAND RIGHT SERVICE ON FOR
FOR THE ID DE COMMUNITY -- WE
ARE WHERE WE OPERATE SIMILARLY
TO UBER AND LIFT IN THE FACT
THAT IF THERE'S A RIDE THAT YOU
NEED AT A YOU KNOW BETWEEN A
CERTAIN TIME.
WE CAN -- PROVIDE IT -- WE ARE
OPEN ONLY TO THE IP DIS --
COMMUNITY.
AND WE PROVIDE CLOSE TO EIGHT
HUNDRED RIDES EVERY MONTH --
MYSELF PERSONALLY -- PROVIDING.
ABOUT -- TEN TO SIXTEEN EVERY
NIGHT FROM -- TWO TO TEN
COVERING ANYWHERE FROM A HUNDRED
FIFTY TO TWO HUNDRED FORTY MILES
AN AND IN A NIGHT -- WE ARE WE
ARE VERY WELL TRAINED AS AS
DRIVERS AND IN MANAGING OUR
SAFETY.
AS WE ARE IN MY OPINION SOME OF
THE SAFEST DRIVERS OUT THERE I
HAVE DRIVEN NEXT TO OUR DRIVERS --
BOTH AT AT WORK AND IN MY
PERSONAL VEHICLE AND WE ARE I
FIND THIS TO BE SOME OF THE
SAFEST OUT THERE -- SAFETY IS
OUR FIRST RAISES NUMBER ONE
PRIORITY -- OUR MOTTO IS IF YOU
CAN'T DO IT SAFELY DON'T DO IT.
AND WE WE HOLD VERY FIRMLY TO
THAT NAME MAKING SURE THAT OUR
CONSUMERS AND CLIENTELE.
ARE TRANSPORTED FROM.
FROM THEIR HOMES TO WORK IN TO
WORK. TO WHERE WHERE WHEREVER
THEY NEED TO GO -- AND SAFELY AS
POSSIBLE EVEN IF IT MEANS TAKING
AND TAKING ON A SLOWER PATH BUT
SAFETY IS ALWAYS OUR NUMBER ONE
PRIORITY.
HI I AM CHRIS THE IMMENSELY.
YEAH I'M ON BEHALF READY RIGHT
IS THE BEST.
INDEPENDENT RIGHT THERE IS -- I
DON'T DRIVE BECAUSE OF MY
EPILEPSY.
I AND OTHER DISABILITY THAT IT
DEVELOP SO I CHOOSE READY RIDE
BECAUSE I DON'T WANT TO DRIVE
AND IT GIVE ME INDEPENDENCE IT'S
AN GRANTED THEY DO HAVE LITTLE.
KINKS IN THE ROAD TO BEING LATE
BUT STILL I'VE NEVER RUN INTO
THOSE GEEKS.
THERE SOMETIMES THEY'RE LATE
SOMETIMES THEY'RE NOT HE'S GOT
TO BE PATIENT WITH THEM.
BUT IT'S THE BEST.
UP RIDE I'VE EVER HAD BEEN WITH.
AND I'VE IN BUSES I'VE DONE
FIRST TRANSIT BUSES AND I'VE
BEEN CITY BUSES AND I LIKE READY
RIGHT BETTER IT KEEPS YOU SAFER
[INAUDIBLE]
PERFECT [INAUDIBLE]
SO -- WHAT I WANTED TO SHARE
WITH YOU I WAS THE AUTHOR OF A
CO AUTHOR OF SB?
ONE WHICH WAS -- PUT SEVEN
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS A YEAR
INTO PUBLIC TRANSIT.
GOING FORWARD AND I JUST
CONNECTED THE DIRECTOR OF
DEVELOPMENT SERVICEMEN DEEPNESS
APART FROM WITH OUR DIRECTOR OF
THE CALIFORNIA TRANSPORTATION
COMMISSION SUSAN BRANSON.
SO WE'RE TALKING ABOUT HOW WE
CAN AUGMENT.
THE SERVICES FOR THE ID
POPULATION THROUGH THAT PROCESS.
SO.
IT'S WORTH MOTION PLEASE SHARE.
I APOLOGIZE I WAS TALKING TOO
FAST AND I FORGOT THAT I HAD A
QUOTE FROM ONE OF THE BEST
GRADES IT'S BEEN WITH US SINCE
THE BEGINNING OF THE PROGRAM.
SO I JUST NEED TO READ THIS YEAR
SO BEING PART OF A MEANS THE
BASKET SERVICES A GREAT PLEASURE.
TO BE BECAUSE NOT ONLY DOES IT
ALLOW ME TO MAKE MY OWN SCHEDULE
BUT IT'S A GREAT FEELING TO HAVE
IN MY HEART TO SEE THAT MY PEERS.
IN THE COMMUNITY YOU GET THE
CHANCE TO LEARN HOW TO GET TO
THEIR DOCTORS.
THEIR WORK.
INSTEAD OF RELYING ON OTHER
PEOPLE I LOVE KNOWING THAT MY
PEERS CAN TRUST ME THEY HAVE
CONFIDENCE IN ME WHEN I AM
SHOWING THEM NEW THINGS.
EVERY DAY I WOULD TO SEE ALL MY
PEOPLE BE ABLE TO DO MORE THAN
THEY KNOW IF YOU PEOPLE JUST
LIKE EVERYONE IN THE WORLD
[INAUDIBLE]
PERFECT.
YOU KNOW ESPECIALLY A COMMUNITY
LIKE READING IT'S VERY SPREAD
OUT AND YOU KNOW TRANSPORTATION
CAN BE EXCEPTIONALLY LIMITING --
IF YOU YOU KNOW -- TO TO TO TO
ACCOMPLISH LIFE YOU TALK ABOUT
INVENTED SO THAT THE WORK YOU'RE
DOING -- VERY IMPORTANT AND
REALLY APPRECIATE IT THANKS SO
MUCH [INAUDIBLE]
YEAH.
THE KNOWLEDGE ABOUT LIKE RIGHT
AWAY -- GROUP IN ROME ONE OF THE
WHAT I UNDERSTAND THE STRUGGLES
OF OF GETTING FOR OVER THOSE
LONG DISTANCES -- ONE OF THE ONE
OF TRIPS I MAKE EVERY NIGHT IS --
ALL THE WAY UP TO LIKE
CALIFORNIA. TO TO MAKE SURE ONE
OF OUR ONE OF OUR CLIENTS GETS
HOME FROM WORK EVERY NIGHT.
AND YOU KNOW THAT THAT IS
CHALLENGING SOMETIMES WITHOUT
WITH THE ROAD CONSTRUCTION
THAT'S GOING ON AND YEAH IT'S
GET BEING ABLE TO TO TRANSPORT --
AND IN A TIMELY MANNER -- THESE
CLIENTS TO THEIR TO THEIR JOBS
TO EVEN IF IT'S THEIR LEISURE
ACTIVITIES -- REALLY REALLY
GIVES ME -- A SENSE OF JOY.
IN THAT I AM HELPING THEM BE
ABLE.
TO MAINTAIN AS COMFORTABLE A
LIFE AS POSSIBLE -- BECAUSE
WITHOUT US SOME OF THEM WOULD
HAVE NO OTHER WAY TO GET ANYWAY --
SO BECAUSE IN SOME AREAS THE THE
REGULAR TRANSIT BUSES AND AND
ROBERT DOESN'T GO OUT TO THE
DIFFERENT AREAS THAT SOME OF OUR
CLIENTS LIVE.
SO IT'S IT'S IT'S A UNIQUE
PLEASURE I WOULD SAY TO TO BE
ABLE TO PROVIDE THAT SERVICE.
THANK YOU FOR THAT.
SO WE'LL GO AHEAD AND MOVE ON TO
OUR NEXT PANEL.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR PRESENTATION --
TRANSITION TO COLLEGE COLLEGE
POST COLLEGE. FOR STUDENTS.
AND HERE THEY COME.
SO OKAY WE'RE NOW WE'RE GOING TO
HEAR ABOUT RESPITE FOR CHILDREN --
AGES ZERO THREE FROM ROBIN
LARSON INTAKE SUPERVISOR FAR
NORTHERN REGIONAL CENTER.
BECAUSE USUALLY TRANSITION TO
COLLEGE.
SEASON.
I GOT AHEAD OF MYSELF.
THEN WE'RE MOVING ON TO THAT.
SO.
CALLS FROM COLLEGE FOR STUDENTS.
HI MY NAME IS SALLY AND RODDY
[INAUDIBLE]
AND THE I INTEND MAINSAIL
COLLEGE PLUS PROGRAM.
I HAVE BEEN IN COLLEGE IN THE
COLLEGE PLEASE FOR THREE YEARS.
AND THIS MONTH I AM CURRENTLY
GRADUATING FROM SHASTA COLLEGE.
I PLAN ON GOING BACK AND TAKING
TWO MORE CLASSES SO.
I REALLY ENJOYED BEING IN
COLLEGE PLUS BECAUSE I REALLY
LIKE CAN YOU KNOW OTHER STUDENTS
IN THE PROGRAM.
ON FRIDAYS WE DO FUN ACTIVITIES
TOGETHER.
I FIND IT TO BE REALLY UNIQUE
BECAUSE I ENJOYED GETTING THE
CHANCE TO LEARN.
A LOT ABOUT OTHER PEOPLE.
AND HOW DIFFERENT PEOPLE ARE.
I HAVE LEARNED.
HOW TO APPROACH PEOPLE?
AND THE PEOPLE SOCIALIZE
DIFFERENTLY.
AND I REALLY ENJOYED GETTING TO
KNOW.
PEOPLE FOR WHO THEY ARE.
RIGHT NOT OF MAKING FROM CLOSE
ENOUGH.
AND TO BE ABLE TO SPEND QUALITY
TIME WITH THEM [INAUDIBLE]
I ALSO.
THE SPACE AND TIME TO COME OUT
OF MY SHOW.
AND LEARN HOW TO MAKE FRIENDS
AND TALK TO PEOPLE.
DURING MY I LS TIME WITH KAYLA.
MY STAFF SUPPORTER.
I AND I ENJOYED THAT SHE HELPED
ME WORK ON MY LIFE SKILLS LIKE
BUDGET IN RUNNING ERRANDS.
SHOPPING AND HOMEWORK.
BEING IN THE COLLEGE BUS PROGRAM.
I HAVE LEARNED HOW TO BUDGET AND
KEEP ON TRACK WITH MY SPENDING.
I HAVE LEARNED HOW.
TO GROCERY SHOP AND ALSO.
HOW TO USE THE SELF CHECKOUT?
AT THE GROCERY STORE.
COLLEGE PLUS HAS HELPED HAS
PROVIDED ME WITH SO MUCH
ENCOURAGEMENT AND SUPPORT IN
COLLEGE PLUS.
BY GIVING ME REMINDERS. TO FOCUS
ON MY ASSIGNMENTS COMPLETED ON
TIME.
WE CREATED A CODE WORD.
THAT HELPED ME UNDERSTAND IN THE
MOMENT.
THAT I WAS NOT FOCUSED.
ON THAT HELPS ME OUT A LOT.
THE STAFF HELP ME UNDERSTAND HOW
TO COMPLETE.
ASSIGNMENTS.
AND WHEN I DID NOT UNDERSTAND
THE ASSIGNMENT.
THEY HELPED EXPLAIN IT IN
DIFFERENT WAYS [INAUDIBLE]
SO.
SO I COULD UNDERSTAND.
WHAT I WAS SUPPOSED TO DO?
I HAVE ALSO LEARNED THAT
EVERYDAY IS A LEARNING
OPPORTUNITY.
BEEN IN COLLEGE PLUSES HELP ME
RAISE MY SELF ESTEEM BECAUSE IT
HAS BEEN SO AMAZING. TO HAVE THE
SUPPORT OF THE STAFF.
AND THE OTHER STUDENTS.
THERE FOR ME.
AND ACCESS MY SUPPORT SYSTEM.
WHEN I NEEDED HELP?
COLLEGE PLUS IS VERY IMPORTANT
TO ME BECAUSE IT IT'S A GREAT
OPPORTUNITY TO MEET NEW PEOPLE.
AND THIS PROGRAM HELP MAKE COME
OUT OF MY SHELL [INAUDIBLE]
I AT I HAVE BEEN VERY PROUD TO
BE A PART OF THIS PROGRAM.
COLLEGE PLUS.
NO TO BE COURT TO BE PART COACH
BLISS.
AS I SAID IN THE BEGINNING I AM
GRADUATING FROM JUST A COLLEGES
TO CERTIFICATES. ONE IN COLLEGE
SUCCESS.
AND ONE IN BUSINESS.
I TRULY FEEL.
LIKE I COULD NOT HAVE DONE IT
WITHOUT THE SUPPORT OF THE
COLLEGE BLISS.
THIS IS A GREAT PROGRAM AND IT
SHOULD BE AROUND FOR YEARS TO
COME.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH [INAUDIBLE]
NEXT WEEK.
JUST SUPPORT WELL YOU KNOW WHAT
THANK YOU. FOR YOUR A
PRESENTATION AND VERY PROUD TO
AND CONGRATULATIONS ON YOUR
GRADUATION [INAUDIBLE]
OKAY.
WE WANT YOU TO BE VOCAL SUPPORT.
I HAVE A BASE WITH SOMETHIN SAY.
MY NAME IS NICHOLAS JOHNSON HIGH
FOR RAIN.
ON MY ONE THING I'VE BEEN
STRUGGLING WITH.
AGREED ALL RIGHT TO ALL RIGHT
THE TRIP WE ADD ON AS PHYSICALLY.
THE SOCIAL SECURITY AND SSI.
MOST HERE AGREE ON THIS.
SOME ME ON PEOPLE CANNOT WORK.
AND ON THE SAME.
THAT'S A THREE MY OPINION.
AND I WILL THAT'S WHY I'M TRYING
TO SAVE A THREE THOUSAND THIS
VALIDATES AND SOUND ART PEOPLE
I'VE BEEN STRUGGLING WITH THAT.
AND THAT'S FUN TRYING TO SAY.
UNDERSTOOD. FIVE THREE OF MY
FRIENDS. TO REMOVE FOR NEXT
PANEL THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PRESENTATION AGAIN GRADS.
RIGHT. TO GRADUATE THE CHANCE.
TONGUE TIED.
SO WE'RE GONNA GO BACK -- TO AND
THINK OUR COLLEGE PLUS STUDENTS --
BUT NOW WE'RE GONNA HEAR ABOUT
RESPITE FOR CHILDREN AGES SIX
ZERO THREE FROM ROBIN LARCENY
TAKES A VISOR IT FAR NORTHERN
REGIONAL CENTER.
THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME THIS
EVENING AND I AGREE WITH TAMMY
THOSE ARE REALLY HARD ACTS TO
FOLLOW.
I'M ROBIN LARSON I'VE WORKED AT
FOR NORTHERN REGIONAL CENTER FOR
THIRTY YEARS AND BEEN IN THE
FIELD OF DEVELOPMENTAL SAYS
DISABILITIES FOR FORTY FIVE PLUS
YEARS WHEN YOU START WHEN YOU'RE.
FIVE THIS IS YOUR MY MY
EXPERIENCE GIVES ME A HISTORICAL
PERSPECTIVE ON THE FEDERALLY
MANDATED EARLY START PROGRAM.
THE EARLY START PROGRAM IS FOR
CHILDREN BIRTH TO THREE WHO ARE
AT HIGH RISK FOR A DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITY.
THOSE CHILDREN WHO QUALIFY ARE
ELIGIBLE TO RECEIVE REQUIRED
EARLY INTERVENTION SERVICES SUCH
AS SPEECH.
OCCUPATIONAL PHYSICAL THERAPIES
AS WELL AS DEVELOPMENTAL
SERVICES.
PRIOR TO TWO THOUSAND AND NINE
REGIONAL CENTERS WERE ABLE TO
PURCHASE NINE FEDERALLY REQUIRED
SERVICES TO HELP SUPPORT PARENTS
OF THE CHILDREN WHO QUALIFIED
FOR THIS BENEFICIAL PROGRAM.
IN TWO THOUSAND AND NINE TRAILER
BILL AB X. FOUR NINE AMENDED
SECTION THREE GOVERNMENT CODE
NINETY FIVE OO TWO OO.
MEETING REGIONAL CENTERS FROM
PURCHASING NON REQUIRED SERVICES.
AMONG THE NON REQUIRED SERVICES
THAT REMAIN PROHIBITED IS
RESPITE SERVICES.
THOSE OF US WHO ARE PARENTS.
MOST LIKELY WOULD AGREE THAT
RAISING CHILDREN IS ONE OF THE
MOST CHALLENGING BUT REWARDING
EXPERIENCES THAT WE CAN HAVE.
THE MAJORITY OF CHILDREN ARE
BORN WITHOUT COMPLICATIONS IN
CARING FOR THESE TYPICALLY
DEVELOPING CHILDREN OFTEN
CHALLENGES US. TO OUR MAXIMUM
CAPACITIES.
THE CHILDREN WHO WE SERVE AN
EARLY START ARE NOT THESE
CHILDREN.
THERE PRESS THEY PRESENT WITH
MEDICAL CONDITIONS.
SERIOUS BEHAVIORS AND THE
INABILITY TO COMMUNICATE MAKING
PARENTING EVEN MORE DEMANDING.
IMAGINE FOR A MOMENT THAT YOUR
CHILD WAS BORN WITH A HIGH RISK
CONDITION AND HOSPITALIZED FOR
THE FIRST THREE MONTHS OF THEIR
LIFE.
THE CLOSEST CARE FOR YOUR CHILD
IS UC DAVIS A HUNDRED AND FIFTY
FIVE MILES ONE WAY.
YOU SPEND THOSE THREE MONTHS
GOING BACK AND FORTH TO THE
HOSPITAL TO VISIT WHILE CARING
FOR YOUR TWO OTHER CHILDREN AND
TRYING TO KEEP YOUR JOB.
BUT YOU'VE DONE IT.
YOUR CHILD IS NOW HOME BUT NOT
DEVELOPING NORMALLY.
HE QUALIFIES FOR EARLY START
SERVICES HOWEVER BECAUSE OF HIS
WRIST CONDITION.
YOUR EXHAUSTED AND NEED AN
OCCASIONAL BREAK AS ALL PARENTS
DO.
THERE BUT THERE IS NO ONE
QUALIFIED TO CARE FOR YOUR CHILD.
THIS IS THE SITUATION THAT MANY
OF OUR PARENTS FACE.
THEY HAVE NO ONE TO GIVE THEM
THE OPPORTUNITY FOR THE SELF
CARE THAT IS DESPERATELY NEEDED.
UNFORTUNATELY WHAT OFTEN SUFFERS
FROM THE SITUATION IS THE
CRITICAL QUALITY BONDING THAT IS
NEEDED FOR ALL CHILDREN TO GROW
AND DEVELOP.
WHEN LOOKING AT?
WHEN LOOKING AT THE DEVELOPMENT
OF A CHILD WE NEED TO TAKE INTO
CONSIDERATION THE WHOLE CHILD?
IN ADDITION THE THERAPIES
PARENTS NEED OTHER SUPPORT SUCH
AS AN OCCASIONAL BREAK TO BE THE
BEST PARENTS THAT THEY CAN BE.
DOCTOR BRUCE PERRY A CLINICIAN
AND A RESEARCHER IN THE AREAS OF
NEUROSCIENCE AND CHILDHOOD
MENTAL HELP.
STATES FOR EVERY DOLLAR SPENT IN
EARLY INTERVENTION. NINE DOLLARS
IS SAVED OVER THE LIFETIME OF
THE CHILD.
RESPITE IS A SMALL PRICE TO PAY
FOR A CHILD'S FUTURE.
I MY COLLEAGUES IN THE PARENTS
THAT WE SERVE.
HOPE THAT YOU'LL CONSIDER
THOUGHTFUL LEGISLATION THAT DOES
NOT USURP PARENTAL
RESPONSIBILITY BUT SPORTS
PARENTS TO RAISE THEIR AT RISK
CHILDREN TO MAXIMIZE THEIR
SKILLS.
I GIVEN THE REGIONAL CENTER THE
ABILITY ONCE AGAIN TO PURCHASE
RESPITE CARE FOR THESE CHILDREN
ZERO TO THREE WHO REALLY NEED IT.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ROBIN -- THAT WAS
WONDERFUL ON HERE FOR ME ON THAT
AND YOU KNOW WHAT WE'RE GOING TO
DO SOMETHING -- NOW WE'RE GONNA
MOVE ON TO PUBLIC COMMENTS.
SO THIS IS WHERE WE HEAR FROM
YOU.
OTHER REASON MORE HERE BASICALLY.
AND SO COME ON UP TO THE
MICROPHONE TO SHARE YOUR STORY.
IS IN THE INTEREST OF TIME
INSURING EVERYBODY HAS A CHANCE
TO SPEAK.
PLEASE LEAVE YOUR COMMENTS TO
COUPLE MINUTES JENNIFER ON MY MY
LEFT WILL HAVE A TIME CARD.
WHEN YOU'RE DONE AND I WILL BE
VERY VERY OF?
HELPFUL IN SHARING WITH YOU IT'S
YOUR TIME -- SO PLEASE COME TO
THE MICROPHONE IF YOU HAVE
ANYTHING YOU WOULD LIKE TO SHARE
IS A PUBLIC COMMENT.
WE'RE HERE TO HEAR FROM YOU AND
AND AND AGAIN A LOT OF
LEGISLATION HAS BEEN DERIVED OUT
OF THE PARENTS.
NEEDS TO BE ALIVE [INAUDIBLE]
YEAH.
JUST FORM A LINE IN OF LIKE IT'S
TOO LONG YOU KNOW YOU YOU KNOW
YOU CAN SEND JUMP IN WHEN YOU
CAN.
QUE.
PLEASE TAKE YOUR NAME.
AND WE'RE FROM.
HELLO MY NAME IS RON TO DELIVER
AND I AM FROM YOU COUNTY -- I
WAS IN PARADISE BUT IT WILL BE
ACTUALLY MOVING TO SHASTA COUNTY
SHORTLY DUE TO THE CAMPFIRE.
I JUST FIRST WANTED TO SAY THANK
YOU FOR TAKING TIME TO COME TO
READING TO HEAR WHAT THE
COMMUNITY HAS TO SAY REGARDING
THE REGIONAL CENTERS.
I HAVE A TWENTY ONE YEAR OLD SON
NAMED COLIN AND HE HAS AUTISM.
CALL HAS BEEN A CLIENT WITH FAR
NORTHERN REGIONAL CENTER FOR
ABOUT TWENTY YEARS.
REGIONAL CENTERS ARE UNIQUE IN
THAT THEY PROVIDE SERVICES FROM
BIRTH TO DEATH.
THAT'S ACTUALLY A VERY
COMFORTING THOUGHT BECAUSE IN
OUR SITUATION CALLING DOESN'T
HAVE ANY BROTHERS OR SISTERS OR
FAMILY TO TAKE CARE OF HIM AFTER
WORK ON HIS SERVICE COORDINATOR
IS A POINT OF CONTACT AND WORKS
WITH HIM AND US TO HELP HIM
ACHIEVE WHAT IS IMPORTANT TO AND
NECESSARY. FOR HIM TO LIVE A
HAPPY HEALTHY AND PRODUCTIVE
LIFE IN HIS COMMUNITY.
WE ARE VERY GRATEFUL TO FAR
NORTHERN FOR THE VARIOUS
SERVICES THEY PROVIDED TO HIM
OVER THE YEARS.
FROM EARLY INTERVENTION
DIAGNOSTICS ABA SPEECH THERAPY
SOCIAL RACK RESPITE ETCETERA.
OF COURSE SOME OF THE SERVICES
WERE PROVIDED MANY MANY YEARS
AGO BEFORE THE BUDGET CUTS A TWO
THOUSAND AND NINE SUSPENDED MANY
OF THOSE SERVICES.
BUT MY POINT IS FAR NORTHERN HAS
HELPED HIM BECOME THE YOUNG MAN
HE IS TODAY.
HE IS ATTENDING BUTTE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE AND IS NOW LOOKING AT
WHAT HE WANTS TO DO WITH HIS
LIFE.
THIS IS NOT TO SUGAR COAT ALL OF
THE OBSTACLES AND CHALLENGES HE
FACES ON A DAILY BASIS.
BUT WE KNOW THAT THERE ARE
OPTIONS THAT CAN HELP HIM LIVE
AS INDEPENDENTLY AS POSSIBLE
WITH FAR NORTHERN HELP. FOR
NORTHERN TAKES AN OBSTACLE IN
OUR CHALLENGE AND LOOKS FOR
CREATIVE SOLUTIONS TO IT.
WITH PERSON CENTERED PLANNING AS
THE BASIS FOR ALL INDIVIDUAL
PROGRAM PLANS AND DECISIONS MADE
BY THE CLIENTS.
THE POSSIBILITIES ARE ENDLESS.
INSTEAD OF SAYING NO THAT CAN'T
BE DONE THE RESPONSE IS YES AND
HOW CAN WE HELP YOU ACCOMPLISH
THAT GOAL.
TONIGHT YOU HAVE HEARD ABOUT
MANY OF THOSE CREATIVE OUT OF
THE BOX IDEAS.
IT'S ALL VARIOUS ISSUES SUCH AS
TRANSPORTATION AND EMPLOYMENT.
YOU'VE HEARD FROM SELF ADVOCATES
THAT OUR LEADERS NOT ONLY IN
THIS COMMUNITY BUT THROUGHOUT
THE STATE. FOR NORTHERN IS KNOWN
AND RESPECTED THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA AS AN INNOVATIVE
CENTER WITH A HIGH RATE OF
EMPLOYMENT.
BUT LIKE OTHER REGIONAL CENTERS
IN THE STATE WE ALSO FACE MANY
CHALLENGES HERE ARE JUST A FEW.
AFFORDABLE HOUSING FOR SOMEONE
ON SSI.
NEED TO REPEAL THE SUSPENSION OF
SERVICES FROM TWO THOUSAND AND
NINE THAT WERE IMPLEMENTED DUE
TO THE BUDGET CUTS.
IN OPERATIONS FUNDING.
REGIONAL CENTERS CANNOT CONTINUE
TO FUNCTION WITH SO MANY
UNFUNDED MANDATES. FOR MANY
YEARS WE HAVE HAD THE SAME
SERVICE COORDINATOR AND SHE MADE
SO MUCH PROGRESS WITH COLIN.
BUT WITH EVER INCREASING
CASELOADS SERVICE COORDINATORS
CANNOT POSSIBLY SPEND THE AMOUNT
OF TIME THAT IS REQUIRED. TO
TRULY KNOW THEIR CLIENTS AND
FAMILIES AS WELL AS THEY COULD
AND SHOULD -- AND WELL AS A
PARENT.
I MOSTLY CONCERNED WITH THE
OTHER SIDE OF THE BUDGET THE
PURCHASE A SERVICE DOLLARS WHICH
EQUATES TO SERVICES FOR MY SON.
I REALIZE THE IMPLICATIONS OF
NOT HAVING ADEQUATE STAFF TO
CARRY OUT THIS CASE MANAGEMENT
DUTIES AND THAT IT WILL DIRECTLY
AFFECT MY SON AS WELL.
REGIONAL CENTER OPERATION NEEDS
HAVE LONG BEEN NEGLECTED WHILE
THE WORKLOAD HAS INCREASED.
I'LL MAKE IT QUICK YES PLEASE.
MY SON IS VERY LUCKY TO BE A
FARM OR THE REGIONAL CENTER
CLIENT.
WE HAVE A PHENOMENAL REGIONAL
CENTER THAT TRULY HAS THE BEST
INTEREST OF THE INDIVIDUALS THEY
SERVE AT HEART. FOR NORTHERN IS
WELL KNOWN FOR THEIR CREATIVITY
AND FOR WORKING COLLABORATIVELY
WITH VARIOUS PROVIDERS
BUSINESSES AND COMMUNITY
AGENCIES.
THERE IS NO I IN TEAM BECAUSE
TEAM STANCE FOR TOGETHER
EVERYONE ACHIEVES MORE.
AND FAR NORTHERN IS VERY LARGE
PART OF MY FAMILY'S TEAM.
I CANNOT WAIT TO SEE WHERE MY
SON STREAMS TAKE HIM THE
POSSIBILITIES ARE ENDLESS I HOPE
OUR FAMILY CAN COUNT ON YOU TO
CONTINUE TO SUPPORT FAR NORTHERN
REGIONAL CENTER THANK YOU.
THE NEXT SPEAKER PLEASE.
YES SIR.
ON A I DON'T OKAY BE SHORT AND
SWEET.
I GOTTA GIVE KUDOS TO THE FAR
NORTHERN THEY'VE BEEN TAKING
CARE OF MY MY SON MY OLDEST SON
FOR OVER THIRTY YEARS -- HE
DOESN'T WANT TO LIVE WITH US
HE'S JUST LIKE TO SAY THIRTY
YEARS OLD PLUS AND HE DOESN'T
WANT TO LIVE WITH HIS FAMILY HE
DOES HIS OWN THING AND FOR NO
THERE'S MADE THAT.
MAKE SURE THAT'S HAPPENED.
WHICH I'M VERY GRATEFUL FOR THAT.
AND I'M GONNA GO TO ANOTHER
THING MY WIFE IS DEATH AND A LOT
OF OUR GOVERNMENT BUILDINGS DO
NOT HAVE.
INTERPRETERS.
IN OUR GOVERNMENT BUILDINGS.
I GOTTA GIVE FOUR NEAR THE GROUP --
DOES AGAIN BECAUSE WE HAVE AN
INTERPRETER.
BUT SO SECURITY.
THE CITY ALL HERE.
THE JAIL.
NO INTERPRETER.
AND THERE NEEDS TO BE AN
INTERPRETER AT EVERY GOVERNMENT
BUILDING.
EVERY GOVERNMENT BUILDING.
WE GOT -- THREE SECURITY GUARDS
ESOS SECURITY HERE IN TOWN.
NOW ONE INTERPRETER TOOK ME
TWENTY MINUTES. TO GET.
THE COMPUTER STRAIGHTENED OUT
AND IT'S NOT AS PERSONAL.
IT'S PERSONAL WITH AN
INTERPRETER.
AND SO DE PEOPLE HAVE A PROBLEM
WITH THIS I DON'T WANT TO BE
AROUND AS HEARING PEOPLE.
OVER THIS LACK OF COMMUNICATION
IS REALLY BAD.
A MOVIE WITH THAT GIVE THE NEXT
PERSON.
SIR CAN YOU STATE YOUR NAME FOR
THE RECORD PLEASE.
MICHAEL LEWIS THANK YOU MICHAEL.
MICHAEL I THINK RESPONSE TO HAVE.
A WORD.
NO I WAS JUST HAVING I THINKS
IT'S VERY VERY -- I OPENING WHAT
YOU'RE SAYING ABOUT THE SECURITY
GUARDS IN THE INTERPRETERS
[INAUDIBLE]
SHOCKING REALLY.
THANK YOU MICHAEL FOR THE PLEASE
STATE YOUR NAME [INAUDIBLE]
RATHER TALK [INAUDIBLE]
HI.
SORRY MY NAME IS ERIN O'BRIEN
AND I'M COMING HERE TONIGHT TO
REPRESENT TO MODOC COUNTY.
WE ARE RURAL COMMUNITY ABOUT TWO
AND A HALF.
HOURS STRAIGHT EAST OF READING.
AND FIVE YEARS AGO MY SISTER WHO
IS ALSO DEVELOPMENTALLY DISABLED.
CAME TO LIVE WITH ME DUE TO OUR
BROTHER WHO CARED FOR HER -- FOR
ABOUT THIRTEEN YEARS PASSED AWAY
FROM CANCER.
SO WE HAD A DIFFICULT TIME
FINDING A PLACE FOR OUR SISTER.
IN A IN HOME CARE SETTING THAT
HAD AVAILABLE ROOM.
LIKE WE'VE HEARD TONIGHT.
OF FROM OTHER CONSUMERS HERE
ABOUT HOUSING AND ABOUT
DIFFICULTIES FINDING PLACES THAT
ARE SAFE.
THAT IS KIND OF THE PROBLEM THAT
WE CAME.
TO SO AFTER A FAMILY MEETING WE
DECIDED THAT MY SISTER WOULD
COME TO LIVE WITH ME WHICH WAS A
BIG CHANGE OF LIFE FOR ME.
BUT I'M NOT SORRY I'VE HAD.
TREMENDOUS CHALLENGES I'VE HAD A
LOT OF EDUCATION.
AND I AM STILL LEARNING SO MUCH
AND I LOVE HER AND LIKE ANY
PARENT THOUGH SHE'S NOT MY CHILD.
I WANT HER TO BE GIVEN SAFE
LOVING CARE AND DIGNITY.
BUT ALSO AS A CARETAKER OR CARE
GIVER.
I WANT DIGNITY.
AND UNTIL A WEEK AGO MY SISTER
DID NOT QUALIFY BECAUSE OF SSI
FOR MEDI CAL.
IF YOU DO NOT HAVE MEDI CAL.
YOU DO NOT RECEIVE PAYMENT FOR
BEING A FULL TIME CARE TAKER.
I CANNOT CARRY A FULL TIME JOB
AND BE A FULL TIME CARE TAKER
THAT IS MY PERSONAL.
ISSUE THAT I WANTED TO BRING TO
THE TABLE TONIGHT.
BUT ALSO AS A PERSON INVOLVED
WITH NO FAR NORTHERN REGIONAL --
BEING A REPRESENTATIVE FOR THE
BOARD OF DIRECTORS FROM MODOC
COUNTY.
WE ARE BEING -- INUNDATED WITH A
LOT OF CHALLENGES BECAUSE WE ARE
RURAL.
AND THE DISTANCE TO COME TO
READING IS A BIG DEAL.
AND FOR PEOPLE WITH
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES WE
HAVE TO KIND OF HONE IN ON OUR
OWN COMMUNITY TO GET THOSE NEEDS
MET.
AND SOMETIMES THEY ARE NOT MET
ON EVERY LEVEL THAT WE'VE HEARD
HERE TONIGHT WITH CALL SERVICES
FOR PEOPLE FOR SUPPORT THAT IS
NOT AVAILABLE -- EMERGENCY
SERVICES HAVE TO BE THROUGH THE
HOSPITAL.
THANK YOU SO MUCH THANK YOU VERY
MUCH JUST TO SHARE WITH YOU.
THAT I ACTUALLY REPAIRING A BILL
TO CREATE SATELLITE REGIONAL
CENTERS IN RURAL AREAS.
AND I THINK WE TALKED ON THE
PHONE THE OTHER DAY ABOUT -- THE
THE LIVE STREAM TO THANK YOU FOR
MAKING THE LONG DRIVE DOWN TO BE
YOUR PERSONAL BRIDGE FOR SURE
IT'S A LOT.
WE STATE YOUR NAME.
SLATS BOMB AND ONE OF THE THINGS
I HAVE FOUND BY VARIOUS MEETINGS
AFTER EIGHT YEARS I AM A GRAND
PARENTS WHOSE PARENTING.
THERE ARE A LOT OF PEOPLE IN
THIS AREA.
THAT ARE DOING THAT.
OUR I WAS GOING AT ONE TIME TO
RATTLE FAMILY EMPOWERMENT AND
THEY HAD A CLASS OR A MEETING
ONCE A WEEK FOR PARENTS WERE
GRANT.
AND CURRENT PARENTS WHO ARE
PARENTING THEIR CHILD AT THIS IS
A THANK GOODNESS THAT THERE WAS
FAR NORTHERN.
AS WE'VE HAD HIM. FOR TEN YEARS
IS NOW NINETEEN WE CAME AT HE
CAME WHEN HE WAS EIGHT AND HE
WAS A FAR FAR -- BATTLING MIDDLE
WHATEVER REGIONAL AND IN NOW FAR
NORTHERN REGIONAL.
THAT WE GET THE RESPITE FROM
THAT BUT WE'RE NOT GETTING AS
MUCH AS WE USED TO THIRD AND
MOST OF THAT WAS THROUGH.
OUR ROLF FAMILY EMPOWERMENT WE
GET SET WHICH IS ALSO FUNDED
THAT WAY IS THROUGH ROUNDEL
FAMILY EMPOWERMENT BUT POT
SPONSORED BY.
I MEAN MONEY GIVEN FROM FAR
NORTHERN.
OUR BIGGEST PROBLEM IS THAT MY
HUSBAND'S JUST HAD A STROKE.
AND I AM SEVENTY SIX AND HE HAS
SEVENTY SEVEN AND ROW IS TRYING
TO HELP US FIND HOUSING.
I KNOW ALL OF THESE PEOPLE WHO
IT'S JUST THEIR CHILD WHAT NOW
IT'S I AM THE GRANDPARENT AND
I'M NOT THE ONLY ONE AROUND HERE.
BECAUSE AFTER BEING IN THE
MEETINGS AND BEING IN MEETINGS
FOR THE LAST TEN YEARS.
I LEARNED AYE HE P. FROM FAR
NORTHERN ALL THESE THINGS THAT I
HAD TO HAVE. TO TELL PEOPLE AND
THERE ARE SO MANY YOUNG PEOPLE
WHO HAVE KIDS.
LIKE MY GRANDSON WHO DO NOT KNOW
ABOUT FAR NORTHERN OR THAT THEY
CAN EVEN APPLY BECAUSE WHEN I GO
TO MEETINGS LIKE IT I EP SCHOOL
AND DIFFERENT THINGS.
I MADE A LIST BECAUSE I HAVE
ANOTHER LADY THAT I MET WHEN I
TAKE MY GRANDSON TO THE NORTH
AMERICAN MENTAL HEALTH CENTER.
WHO HAS AN EIGHT YEAR OLD JUST
THAT THE AGE OF MINE WAS WHEN I
GOT MY GRANDSON AND I JUST GAVE
HER THIS LIST THAT HAS FAR
NORTHERN AND IT HAS RUN OUR
FAMILY EMPOWERMENT?
IT HAS SPECIAL OLYMPICS NOBODY'S
MENTIONED SPECIAL OLYMPICS
BECAUSE WE NEED THAT THIS KID.
NEEDS ADD UP TO BE ABLE TO HAVE
SPORTS AND HIS WIFE.
THE REST OF HIS LIFE AND THANK
GOODNESS THERE IS A REALLY NICE
GROUP WE DON'T HAVE QUITE AS
MANY THINGS THAT WE GET TO DO AS
THE PEOPLE AND SHE GO.
BUT WE'RE WORKING ON IT BECAUSE
WE'VE GOT TO HAVE VOLUNTEERS SO
WE'RE LOOKING MORE FOR MORE ON
THERE ARE ALSO OTHER PLACES TO
GET RESPITE.
SOMETIMES THERE IS NEIGHBORHOOD
CHURCH WHICH ONE TIME A MONTH
HAS A RESPITE.
AND YOU CAN BRING YOUR CHILD
THERE -- AND THEY HAVE TWO AND A
HALF HOURS AND I GET SOMETHING
TO EAT AND I GET TO PLAY WITH
KIDS THEIR OWN AGE SO THERE ARE
A LOT OF THINGS THAT YOU.
THAT YOU HAVE TO NETWORK ARE YOU
DON'T EVEN KNOW THAT ARE OUT
THERE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR THAT
THANK YOU.
LOG DEL LOCKWOOD WITH THE SHASTA
COUNTY HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES
AGENCY.
AND WE HAVE A REGIONAL SERVICES
OFFICES THROUGHOUT SHASTA COUNTY
WHICH IS VERY BROAD SO IGNITION
SHASTA COUNTY IN OFFICE AND
BERNIE WE'VE OFFICES IN ANDERSON
IN COTTON WOULD.
SHASTA LAKE LAKE HAD TWO OFFICES
IN REDDING ENTERPRISE IN
DOWNTOWN RATING -- WE APPRECIATE
ALL YOUR WORK TO ASSIST PEOPLE
DISABILITIES AND ESPECIALLY WITH
TRANSPORTATION -- WE WANT TO
MAKE A COMMENT ABOUT THE DDS
RATE STUDY -- THAT SOME OF THE
FORMULAS AND PROPOSE NEW RATES
DON'T REALLY WORK FOR RURAL
AREAS WHERE WE HAVE A LARGE
DISTANCES TO TRAVEL.
THE PROPOSED RATE IS BASED ON A
AN AVERAGE TRIP OF TWENTY FIVE
MILES.
THAT DOESN'T WORK FOR PEOPLE
THAT LIVE IN RURAL AREAS AND YOU
TRANSPORTATION FROM A GREAT
DISTANCE.
SO WE WOULD APPRECIATE
CONSIDERING A PER MILE RATE --
PROPOSAL FOR THE NEW -- RATES
THAT ARE BEING PROPOSED AND THEN
FOR ALL SERVICE PROVIDERS ALL
DIRECT SERVICE PROFESSIONALS ARE
OVERWORKED OVERWHELMED AND UNDER
APPRECIATED.
THE COSTS THAT WERE REPORTED TO
DDS FOR THE RATES STEADY WITH A
COSTS FROM LAST YEAR.
AND THEY NEED RATES FOR NEXT
YEAR'S COSTS SO RIGHT OFF THE
BAT -- THERE'S AN 8210% INCREASE
THAT'S NEEDED IN THE PROPOSAL'S
BECAUSE THE RATES ARE TO COVER --
THE COST OF THE UP COMING YEAR.
AND WE PER SHARE CONSIDERING
CONSIDERING THAT I ALSO WANT I
YOU MENTIONED EARLIER YOUR
SUPPORT FOR TAX CREDITS THANK
YOU FOR DOING THAT WE ALSO HAVE
USED THE STATE TERRIBLY PROGRAM
TO HELP PEOPLE DISABILITIES GET
STATE EMPLOYMENT -- WE'D
APPRECIATE EXPANSION OF OF THAT
AS WELL THANK YOU [INAUDIBLE]
THAT.
PLEASE STATE YOUR NAME
[INAUDIBLE]
HI -- MY NAME IS SALLY ANDREOTTI.
I WAS BORN IN NINETEEN NINETY
TWO I WAS BORN WITH THE
DEVELOPMENT OF DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITY CALLED MILD
INTELLECTUAL.
I HAD.
A HARD TIME READING.
HARD TIME WRITING.
I HAD A HARD TIME LEARNING
GROWING UP.
SO ONE OF THE THINGS THAT I HAD
TO LEARN WHEN I WAS GOING TO
COLLEGE WAS.
PEOPLE DON'T ALWAYS GIVE ME THE
ANSWER IN THIS YOU ASKED.
FOR YOU HAVE TO BE ABLE TO SPEAK
UP.
AND THAT'S WHAT KIND OF COLLEGE
PLUSES HELP ME DO [INAUDIBLE]
WAS. TO ADD TO SELF ADVOCATE FOR
MYSELF [INAUDIBLE]
AND THERE'S I KNOW THERE'S BEEN
A LOT OF ENCOURAGEMENT AS I WAS
SAYING EARLIER.
AND I HAVE BEEN ABLE. TO SERVE
ADVOCATE FOR MYSELF YOU KNOW HEY
I DON'T LIKE THIS OR CAN YOU
PLEASE NOT DO THIS [INAUDIBLE]
AND IT'S REALLY HELPED ME.
DEVELOP MY SELF ESTEEM
[INAUDIBLE]
AND WHAT'S IT GONNA SAY -- YEAH
WHEN I WAS GOING TO MIDDLE
SCHOOL.
I WENT TO THE LEARNING CENTER.
MY MIDDLE SCHOOL THAT I WENT TO
WAS EVERGREEN ELEMENTARY
[INAUDIBLE]
AND THEY HELPED ME LEARN TO READ
TO HELP ME LEARN TO WRITE.
AND IF IT WASN'T FOR THE THE
SERVICES.
THAT.
THEY PROVIDED.
I WOULDN'T HAVE GOTTEN AS FAR AS
I'VE GOTTEN.
NO DOUBT ABOUT IT.
I LEARNED HOW TO READ I LEARNED
HOW TO WRITE.
I LEARNED HOW TO SPELL FOR
CRYING OUT LOUD.
MY FAVORITE GAME AS SCRABBLE.
THAT'S WHY I LIKE PER GAME SO
MUCH [INAUDIBLE]
SO.
WITH THAT BEING SAID IN.
COLLEGE COLLEGE PLUS.
COMBINED WITH THE EXTRA HELP
THAT I GOT.
GROWING UP.
REALLY JUST LIKE LIFTED ME UP A
LOT.
VERY PROUD OF YOU THANK YOU SO
MUCH [INAUDIBLE]
FOR THAT PRESENTATIONS.
WELL IN THE I'M ALSO HE FINDS
THE FOR NORTHERN REGIONAL CENTER
[INAUDIBLE]
SO [INAUDIBLE]
YOU.
MISTER GENE SIR. FOR THE RECORD.
HI MY NAME IS DAVID MARABELLA I
WORK FOR A LITTLE RED HEN WHICH
YOU HEARD COUPLE OTHER PEOPLE
SPEAK EARLIER.
NOW I JUST WANT TO REINFORCE THE
VALUE OF EMPLOYMENT -- THROUGH
THE SUPPORT OF FAR NORTHERN
REGIONAL CENTER WE EMPLOY.
OVER A HUNDRED SEVENTY FIVE
ADULTS WITH DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES.
I AM INSPIRED EVERY DAY BY THESE
PEOPLE -- WATCHING PEOPLE GROW
EARN A PAYCHECK.
HAVE DIGNITY AND SELF RESPECT.
I'M.
I MEAN IT'S IT'S IT'S AMAZING I
GREW UP IN A TIME WHEN I WAS.
NOT AN EMPLOYMENT BUT WHEN I WAS
GOING TO SCHOOL --
DEVELOPMENTALLY DISABLED
CHILDREN WERE KEPT SEPARATE FROM
US THAT SEPARATE RECESS AT
SEPARATE LUNCH.
AND DUMB PART OF THE VALUE OF
WHAT WE DO IS TO TEACH OF OUR
COMMUNITY THAT THAT'S NOT
ACCEPTABLE AND NOT OKAY.
SORRY WE GET CHOKED UP ON THIS
[INAUDIBLE]
THE I'M SO PART OF IT ONE OF THE
BIGGEST VALUES OF SUPPORT OF
EMPLOYMENT IN HAVING STORES AND
HAVING.
COMMUNITY BASED PROGRAMS IS TO
TEACH PEOPLE WHAT ARE DEALT WITH
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES CAN
DO.
AND TO NOT HIDE THEM IN THE BACK
AND AND JUST TO SHOW THE VALUE
OF BEING PART OF THE COMMUNITY
AND TO KIND OF CHANGE THE
PERCEPTION -- WE STILL HAVE A
LOT OF PEOPLE THERE AND THINGS
ARE CHANGING. FOR THE BETTER BUT
THERE'S STILL A LOT OF PEOPLE
THAT DON'T UNDERSTAND.
THE PEOPLE DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES ARE NOT LESS OR IF
THEY'RE JUST DIFFERENT.
SO THAT'S A VALUED EMPLOYMENT
AND FOR NORTHERN SUPPORTING US
JUST.
HE KNOWS IT IT'S AN AMAZING
THINGS THAT WE REALLY APPRECIATE
IT.
IT TAKES A VILLAGE.
PLEASE TAKE YOUR NAME SIR.
HI MY NAME IS CHRIS BRACE AND
I'M.
SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF MY BROTHER
WHO WAS A CLIENT AT THEIR VIEW.
OF DEVELOPMENTAL CENTER FOR MOST
OF HIS LIFE.
HE WAS BORN SEVERELY DISABLED
AND WONDER THE SPEECH ABOUT THE
EXCELLENT CARE THAT HE RECEIVED.
FOR MOST OF HIS LIFE AT FAIRVIEW.
FELL MOST CENTER NASTY TO
SUPPORT.
THOSE CENTERS THAT ARE OPERATING.
FOR THE PEOPLE THAT ARE SEVERELY
DISABLED LIKE MY BROTHER WHO
NEVER REACHED AN AGE OF A YEAR
OLD.
YES OF MENTAL AGE.
SO IF YOU THANK YOU FOR
SUPPORTING THOSE AND KEEP
SUPPORTING THOSE FOR THOSE
LEVELS OF CLIENTS ABSOLUTELY
FOREVER.
PLEASE STATE YOUR NAME.
HI MY NAME IS LISA LITTLE AND I
AM THE PARENT OF A TWENTY THREE
YEAR OLD WITH SEVERE AUTISM.
HE DOESN'T SPEAK ANY HAS SEVERE
BEHAVIORS.
SINCE THE TURN TWENTY TWO HAS
NOT BEEN A PROGRAM.
THERE HASN'T BEEN A PROGRAM
AVAILABLE FOR HIM INTEL.
JUST LAST NOVEMBER.
HE WAS GOING TO START ONE AND IT
BURNED DOWN.
SO MOST OF THE PROGRAMS NOW ARE
IMPACTED UP HERE.
AND I KEEP HEARING OVER AND OVER
AGAIN FROM.
THE PEOPLE THAT RUN SOME OF THE
PROGRAMS THAT THEY JUST CAN'T
KEEP ANY STAFF THEY HIRE PEOPLE
AND THEY GET TRAINED AND THEY
MOVE ON TO SOMETHING ELSE.
SO.
THE MY SON WHO IS SITTING AT
HOME.
YOU KNOW FOR THE LAST ALMOST TWO
YEARS.
MY OTHER SON MY HUSBAND AND I
ARE TAKING TURNS TO BE WITH HIM
BECAUSE HE HAS TO BE SOMEONE HAS
TO BE WITH THEM.
TWENTY FOUR SEVEN AND WE'RE
LOSING WE'RE LOSING MONEY
BECAUSE WE'RE NOT AT WORK.
AND SO I REALLY.
THE BIGGEST THE BIGGEST -- THING
THAT'S KEEPING HIM OUT OF IS A
PROGRAM IS I BELIEVE PAY FOR
STAFF [INAUDIBLE]
AND SO.
THE STAFF THAT YOU KNOW WHAT
THREE REGIONAL CENTER CAN
REIMBURSE.
THESE -- PROGRAMS TO PAY THEIR
STAFF A DECENT WAGE I MEAN I
THINK I'VE HEARD IT SEVERAL
TIMES FROM SOME OF THESE OTHER
PEOPLE.
THEY'RE GONNA NEED A DECENT WAGE
IT BECAUSE THESE ARE ALWAYS THE
EASIEST PEOPLE TO WORK WITH I
MEAN.
WHY WORK?
DO THIS IF YOU CAN GO.
WORK AT STARBUCKS YOU KNOW MIGHT
BE A LITTLE MORE FUN TO DO THAT
BUT SOME OF THESE KIDS OR YOUNG
ADULTS REALLY NEED.
SOME PEOPLE THAT HAVE BEEN IN
THE FIELD FOR A LONG TIME THEY
NEED PEOPLE THAT.
OF THE COMPASSION AND AREN'T
GOING.
TO CAUSE BEHAVIORS AND WHICH IN
TURN CAN CAUSE SOME DANGEROUS
SITUATIONS YOU KNOW RESTRAINTS
AND STUFF LIKE THAT AND THAT'S
ONE OF MY BIGGEST CONCERNS.
IS A UNTRAINED PERSON.
TRYING TO RESTRAIN MY TO INTERN
TWENTY POUNDS SON BECAUSE
THEY'RE DOING SOMETHING
INAPPROPRIATE.
SO REALLY IF YOU CAN TRY TO LOOK
AT FUNDING INCREASING FUNDING
FOR STAFF.
THAT WORK DIRECTLY WITH THESE
PEOPLE THAT WOULD BE REALLY
WONDERFUL [INAUDIBLE]
LARA.
THERE'S A WAY TO HAVE YOU CAN
CONNECT AND IF THERE'S ANY WAY
WE CAN WORK THREE DS ALSO.
TOOK TO HELP [INAUDIBLE]
THANK YOU.
PLEASE STATE YOUR NAME.
STRUGGLING A BIT [INAUDIBLE]
GOOD EVENING [INAUDIBLE]
PLEASE START.
I'M OF FAR NORTHERN -- KLEIN A
FOR ANOTHER CLIENT FOR NORTHERN
REGION AUSTIN. SIX SIX GO.
THANK GOD MY DREAM TO COME TO A
COMPANY.
HOME.
BEFORE NOW I C<C.CYAN> BEEN LIVING</C>
IN A HOSPITAL [INAUDIBLE]
HOME.
THEY CALL ME HELLO SHE MY LIFE.
NINE MAYBE IN MY DREAM.
MAY I AM MY OWN HOME.
I GET TO DO.
EVER I DON'T WANT IN I DON'T
HAVE TO BE TOLD WHAT TO DO.
WE CUT. FOR NOT HILL JAMES MY
LIFE BEFORE THE STATE'S YEARS
AGO I WILL BE TOLD WHAT TO DO
EVERY DAY.
I ALWAYS HAVE.
DIFFERENT STAFF.
EVERY DAY.
YOU KNOW I ALWAYS SEEN DIFFERENT
STAFF COME AND GO AND I HATED
THAT [INAUDIBLE]
M..
I GOT A JOB WHEN IT CAME TO THIS
COMPANY.
AND I JUST LEFT IT IN JANUARY.
IT WAS MY FAVORITE JOB.
BUT I CHOOSE TO LEAVE IT BECAUSE
I HAVE BEEN IN THE MOVE UP HERE.
TO THIS AREA SO I LEFT IT BUT I
STILL PART OF THIS COMPANY.
AND I THINK FOR NOTED FOR THAT.
AND NOW I GET TO THEM MY DREAM
[INAUDIBLE]
THANK YOU.
VERY PROUD OF YOU THANK YOU.
GOOD EVENING PLEASE STATE YOUR
NAME -- AMBERLEY MA'AM.
AT I DO WORK FOR FOREIGN ON THE
REGIONAL CENTER AND I JUST WANT
TO SAY THAT I DO.
SUPPORT THIS INCREASE FOR ALL
VENDORS AROUND AS WE HAVE A LOT
OF SUPPORT STAFF THAT DO COME
AND GO.
AND WE HAVE A LOT OF PEOPLE THAT
COME IN HOMES AND IT TAKES TIME
TO BUILD RELATIONSHIPS AND WORK
WITH INDIVIDUALS AND FOR PEOPLE
TO OPEN UP ABOUT THEMSELVES.
ABOUT DEEP PERSONAL THINGS THAT
THEY'RE WORKING ON GOING OUT
INTO THE COMMUNITY IN GOING
GROCERY SHOPPING OR GOING TO
COUNSELING APPOINTMENT.
MEDICAL APPOINTMENTS AND THINGS
THAT.
TAKES TIME TO EVEN OPEN TO US
ABOUT WHO WE ONLY GET TO VISIT
WITH THEM FOUR TIMES A YEAR SO
WHEN THEY HAVE A PERSON WHO
COMES INTO THEIR HOME.
AND ESTABLISH THAT RELATIONSHIP
AND FORTUNATELY THEY WROTE THAT
PERSON WORKING WITH THEM HAS TO
MOVE. TO WORK WITH THOSE PEOPLE
TO TRAIN THEM AND THE NEW PEOPLE
COME IN IT'S KIND OF A REVOLVING
CYCLE AT TIMES.
SO.
IT IS SUCH AN IMPORTANT THING
THAT WE NEED SO THAT WE CAN
CONTINUE WORKING AND SHOWING
PROGRESS IN THE LIVES OF THOSE
PEOPLE THAT WE SERVE.
THANK YOU FOR HELPING.
HI -- SO I WOULD LIKE.
ABOUT MAYBE SOME FUNDING I WENT.
EIGHT TERM MATIC EXPERIENCE FIVE
YEARS.
HEADS -- AND JUST RECENTLY GOT
MY DAUGHTER BACK FULL TIME --
BUT THERE'RE WORSE PROBLEMS THAT
I RAN INTO AT THE COURTHOUSE
THAT MEET.
SOME FUNDING THROUGH FOR
NORTHERN OR MAYBE GIVING FUNDING
FOR FOR NORTHERN. TO HELP
PARENTS WHO -- HAVE LOST THEIR
KIDS THE PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES WHO HAVE LOST THEIR
KIDS THERE IS A LOT OF US OUT
THERE -- AND THERE ARE NO
STRUCTURAL WAYS TO GET YOUR
CHILD BACK IF YOU LOSE THEM
THERE IS ONLY A WAY TO GET
GUARDIANSHIP.
FOR GRANDPARENTS OR OTHER PEOPLE
WHO WANT TO WHO WHO HAVE TAKEN
THE CHILD.
SO I WOULD LOVE TO SEE --
FUNDING BECAUSE IT NOT ONLY
HAPPENED TO ME IT ALSO HAPPENED
TO ONE OF MY CO WORKERS.
AFTER I GOT MY DAUGHTER BACK AND
SO I WOULD LOVE TO SEE IS SOME
FUNDING GO TOWARDS MAYBE IT
PARENTS WHO ARE PART OF OUR
NORTHERN WHO HAVE LOST THEIR
KIDS.
OUT CLIENTS OF FOR NORTHERN WHO
HAVE REALLY.
TRIED THEIR BEST TO GET THEM
BACK BUT UNFORTUNATELY AT WITH
MY WITH MY DISABILITY THE IT
TOOK ME FIVE YEARS -- AND THAT
IS REALLY SAD AND I'M HOPING
THAT MAYBE SOME FUNDING
AVAILABILITY FOR THOSE PEOPLE
WHO HAVE TRIED AND WHO HAVE DONE
EVERYTHING BECAUSE I DIDN'T DO
EVERYTHING I WAS SUPPOSED TO IN --
TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN AND THEY
KEPT HER WAY FOR ME BECAUSE OF
MY DISABILITY IT WASN'T BECAUSE
OF WHAT I DID.
AND SO I'M HOPING THAT MAYBE
SOME FUNDING FOR THOSE PARENTS
WHO DON'T HAVE.
I DAD FOR A DOCTOR WHO GOT ME A
LAWYER FINALLY ITSELF JUST
SAYING THAT WOULD BE IT WOULD BE
NICE MAYBE SOME HELP FOR THOSE
PARENTS.
PERFECT THANK YOU SO MUCH
[INAUDIBLE]
HELLO -- WHERE'S I WAS BORN WITH
DYSLEXIA.
MY GRAMMAR WAS THE FIRST ONE WHO
KNOWS IT GOD BLESS YOUR SOUL
SHOULD WE SHE CAN BE HERE TO
HEAR THIS.
AND YOU KNOW IT'S NOT EASY TO
LIVE WOULD JUST WATCH YOUR BEING
DISABLED.
THE HARDEST THINGS WORKING IN A
WORK PROGRAM.
WOULD SOME ATTITUDES THAT CAN
USE YOU KNOW SOME PROGRAMS WHICH
IS UNDERSTANDABLE OF PAYMENT.
BUT THE BIGGEST THING THERE'S
ENCOURAGING PEOPLE IS THE
BIGGEST THING WANT TO KNOW ABOUT
MY JOB HERE WE'RE ENCOURAGING
THESE PEOPLE BECAUSE WE ARE NEXT
GENERATION. TO HELP YOU GUYS GET
BETTER THE NEXT SOCIETY.
AND IF WE DON'T START WORKING ON
NEXT PEOPLE.
WE'RE GONNA GET REALLY MESSED UP
WHEN YOU WORK ON IT NOW.
ALL WORK AND WE STRUGGLING
PORTION NOW [INAUDIBLE]
THANK YOU.
NEXT WEEK -- PLEASE.
HELLO AGAIN I'M MEGAN HE'S GONNA
[INAUDIBLE]
AND WAS BORN WITH AUTISM.
AND I'VE HAD THIS CONDITION MY
WHOLE LIFE AND I WAS BORN ON
THURSDAY MAY SIXTEENTH.
NINETEEN EIGHTY FIVE I'LL BE
THIRTY FOUR AS OF NEXT WEEK --
WHEN I WAS IN THE EARLY YEARS OF
MY LIFE I?
ALWAYS.
TOLD BY MY DOCTORS TUNE.
I WAS MY MOM WAS TOLD BY MY
DOCTORS.
THOUGH I WASN'T ABLE TO LIVE ON
MY OWN -- WASN'T ABLE TO HAVE A
JOB.
I WAS GOING TO END UP IN A AND
I'M I DON'T LIKE TO SAY THIS
BECAUSE IT JUST SOUNDS BUT BUT A
MENTOR INSTANT TO XIN -- BUT
THAT'S WHAT THE DOCTORS TOLD MY
MOM.
BUT A LONG TIME AGO THIRTY YEARS
AGO IS NOT A FACT BUT MY MOM
REFUSED TO LISTEN TO THE DOCTORS
AND SHE WAS ABLE TO RAISE ME TO
BE.
A WONDERFUL WOMAN.
SHE ALONG WAS MY BORDERS DUNCAN --
MICHAEL.
WE'RE THE ONES WHO HELPED ME.
GET TO THE POINT I AM TODAY AND
ALSO I WANT TO THANK MY AUNTIE
LINDA. FOR HELPING ME AS WELL.
WITHOUT PEOPLE I WOULD NOT BE
WHO TOLD ME I COULD NOT LIVE ON
MY OWN.
I COULD NOT HOLD DOWN A JOB.
WELL GUESS WHAT DOCTORS.
I'M LIVING ON MY OWN.
AND I DO HAVE A JOB [INAUDIBLE]
WELL. FOR TWELVE YEARS.
MY TWELVE UNIVERSALLY PERFORMED
WITHIN IS COMING UP THIS OCTOBER
AND I JUST WANT TO SAY THANK YOU
TO FIND MORE THAN.
YEAH A LITTLE LED HIM. FOR
HAVING ME.
ALONE.
BECAUSE WITHOUT YOU GUYS.
AND WITH ALL MY FAMILY.
WITHOUT THE PERSEVERANCE AND
WITHOUT.
ANOTHER THREE OF MY FAMILY AND
AND THE HOUSE OF MY CELL AND
INCLUDING MYSELF.
IF I COULD TALK OF A GOOD DAY
[INAUDIBLE]
INCLUDING MYSELF.
I WOULD NOT BE.
STANDING RIGHT HERE BEFORE YOU.
TWO VERY MUCH.
VERY INSPIRING.
MAKE MEGAN AND WE SPEAK FOR I
THINK IF YOU SPEAK FOR THE WHOLE
ROOM THE RIPPLE SO GLAD YOU'RE
HERE AND THAT THAT DOCTOR WAS
COMPLETELY WRONG.
GOOD HOW FAR NORTHERN REGIONAL
CENTER FOR THE SPORT THEY GAVE
MY MOM.
I WAS. TWO WHEN I GOT TOO FAR
NORTHERN AT THE AGE OF TWO NOW
I'M GOING TO TWENTY SEVEN ON THE
TWENTY FIFTH.
AND WITH ALL THE SPORTS THEY
GAVE TO MY MOM.
AND TO DEAL WITH ME AND MY
ISSUES BECAUSE I WAS NOT BORN
WITH THE DISABILITY AT THE FIRST.
I WAS THE DOCTOR TOLD MY MOM TO
PUT ME ON MEDICINE AND THEY JUST
STUMP THE BUNCH OF MEDICINE ON
TOP OF MY ISSUES THAT I ALREADY
HAVE.
WHEN I WAS BORN?
AND WITHOUT THEM DOING THAT AND
WHAT THEY DID IN THE SUPPORT
THEY GIVE MY MOM.
I WOULDN'T BEEN HERE
[INAUDIBLE]
THANK YOU.
IT WENT ON TREASON MODE LEVEL
ONE FOR NORTHERN IRELAND BE
WHERE I'M AT TODAY.
THE DOCTORS TOLD MY LOAN.
NOT BORN GIGI THREE TANK OR HOME
SHE ONLY GET A LITTLE IT FOR SIX
WEEKS.
AND HERE I AM TODAY.
AND I NOT ONLY WORK FOR AND GALA
MARCH ON THE U..
DOORS J. REGIONAL ADVISORY
COMMITTEE AND I'M ALSO.
THANK YOU CAN FOR STATEWIDE CHAU
HAVEN'T SEEN THAT WORK.
MARCH ONE THAT. TOO AND IT MADE
ME A LOT STRONGER SHOP ADVOCATE
TODAY [INAUDIBLE]
THANK YOU.
WE GOT A BROKEN CHAIN HERE.
YOU ALREADY HEARD FROM ME ONCE.
I KNOW I'M NOT INDEED A SOUTHERN
BAPTIST PREACHING.
I AM I LIED TO YOU OKAY BUT
THERE'S ONE THING WE HAVE TO
UNDERSTAND HERE.
AS OF TODAY.
AND THE TOMORROW I'M STILL THE
BIGGEST ADVOCATE THERE IS
BECAUSE I WILL ALWAYS SPEAK UP
BROTHERS NOW I DON'T HAVE THIS
PROBLEM BECAUSE THANK GOD
BECAUSE OF WORK RELATED.
I AM ABLE TO GET BY
TRANSPORTATION FROM SISKIYOU
COUNTY OF YOUR BEEN THERE TO
READY.
BUT HERE'S THE PROBLEM.
IS THAT SHE SAYS OTHERWISE I
WANT TO KEEP WORKING FOR WE CARE
A LOT BUT THE WHAT'S GOING TO
KEEP THE WORK IT IS BY MEDICAL
PROBLEMS.
AND I'M SPEAKING FOR THE OTHERS
ALSO FOR I CAN GET MY RIGHT TO
WORK AND ALL THAT BUT I'M GONNA
KEEP COMING TO WORK THERE'S
TIMES WHEN I DON'T WORK I WOULD
LIKE TO BE HERE AND READ.
READY TO GET MEDICAL HELP OR
WHATEVER I NEED STILL SISKIYOU
COUNTY WITH A BUNCH OF DOCTORS
WHO ARE JUMPING SHIP AND DON'T
WANT TO TAKE CARE OF ME BECAUSE
THEY DON'T LIKE OUR NEW MEDICAL
PLAN IN THE STATE YOU KNOW WHICH
ONE I'M TALKING ABOUT.
SO THEIR BORDER JUST GOT TO BE
FUNDING TO HELP US COME UP WE
HAVE A BUS SYSTEM ARE SUCH A
BETWEEN SISKIYOU COUNTY.
AND WIDE ENOUGH READY WHY
BECAUSE I WORE ON THE
TRANSPORTATION PART OF THE
COMMITTEE HAVE SISKIYOU COUNTY
PROCESS YOU COUNTY TRANSIT.
AND WHEN THEY BUILT THEIR NEWS
STATION THEY WANTED.
SO WE HAVE TO GO FROM ONE TOWN
TO ANOTHER TO TRY TO CATCH A BUS
TO GO ANYWHERE WE STILL HAVE TO
GET SOMEONE TO GIVE US A RIDE TO
GO TO MOUNT SHASTA OR WHATEVER
THAT BUS IS.
SO AND THEY DIDN'T WANT GO AHEAD
AND SISKIYOU COUNTY IS DEATH
DEATH AS THEY ARE DIDN'T WANT
GREYHOUND TO COME HERE BECAUSE
THEY DON'T WANT TO TAKE CARE OF
THE WHOLE THEY DON'T WANT TO
HOMELESS ON THE BUS.
GET THE HOMELESS BECAUSE YOU'LL
ALWAYS HAVE THE UNDERSTAND SO WE
NEED FUNDING TO DO SOMETHING TO
COLLECT SOME TYPE OF A BUS
SYSTEM PROCESS YOU COUNTY.
AND READY TO ANOTHER TYPE RURAL
AREAS LIKE IT THANK YOU THANK
YOU.
MY NAME IS KIM. FOR THE DEAF AND
HARD OF HEARING IN THE AREA.
AND I'M HERE TONIGHT.
BECAUSE I WANT TO EXPRESS ONE
THING THAT I WANT TO ADD TO IT
EVERYBODY HAS BEEN DISCUSSING.
AND I LOVE ALL THE STORIES AND
EVERYBODY IS HERE TONIGHT.
AND I THINK WHAT WE HAVE SEVERAL
DEAF AND HARD OF HEARING WITH
ADDITIONAL.
DISABILITIES IN THE AREA AND
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA. ONE
CHALLENGE FOR ALL OF THEM IS
COMMUNICATION ACCESS.
I KNOW IT'S HARD TO FIND THE
FUNDING AND TO SET UP
INTERPRETERS AND CAPTIONING IT
CETERA BUT IF YOU DON'T THOSE
PEOPLE MISS OUT FROM
OPPORTUNITIES FOR EMPLOYMENT.
THERE MISS OUT FROM THE
COMMUNITY BECAUSE OF THE
COMMUNICATION LACK OF ACCESS.
AND THEY NEED THE ID DE ISSUES
AS WELL AND SO WHAT I WANT YOU
TO CONSIDER INCREASING MONEY IS
FOR COMMUNICATION ACCESS FOR
THAT GROUP AS WELL THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.
SO WE HAVE A FEW MORE MINUTES IF
ANYBODY IN THE PUBLIC WOULD LIKE
TO SHARE.
SOME CHALLENGES OR CONCERNS OR
EVEN -- THINGS THAT ARE JUST
GREAT IN THEIR LIFE WE'RE HERE
FOR YOU TO SHARE THAT.
DON'T BE BASHFUL.
NO ONE OF THE BEST LEADER SO I
WELL WHAT I'M GONNA DO IS TURN
OVER TO WE HAVE.
ONE WE GO.
AIR FILTER MEANS ALL SERVICES.
LITTLE OUT.
I'M JUST WANT TO SPEAK TO THE
DIRECT SUPPORT PROFESSIONAL --
CONCERN -- WE EMPLOY ABOUT
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY PEOPLE AND
YOU COUNTY SHASTA COUNTY.
I WOULD SAY. 75280% OF THE MAKE
MINIMUM WAGE OUR TURNOVER RATES
ABOUT 4250%.
I'M AND WE NEED TO START VALUING
THEM.
I MEAN THEY'RE NOT.
RECOGNIZED AS A PROFESSION.
AND THEY NEED TO BE THEY'RE
CHANGING PEOPLE'S LIVES AND
CHANGE IN THIS WORLD SOUTH
THAT'S WHAT I HAVE SAID. ONE
MORE SHOT IF ANYBODY WOULD LIKE
TO SHARE NEW EXPERIENCES WITH US
[INAUDIBLE]
THIS EVENING [INAUDIBLE]
SEEING NONE [INAUDIBLE]
CHRIS.
I WAS GONNA SAY -- AGAIN THANK
YOU EVERYONE BUT IT'S BEEN
ESPECIALLY INSPIRING TO HEAR THE
STORIES -- WORK AND EMPLOYMENT
AND YOU KNOW WE TALK A LOT ABOUT
DISABILITIES BUT WE SHOULD BE
TALKING ABOUT THE ABILITIES THAT
PEOPLE HAVE TO CONTRIBUTE TO THE
WORLD AND TO YOUR NEIGHBORS.
AND TO THEIR LIVES AND IT'S IT'S
IT'S BEEN REALLY INSPIRING TO ME
TO HEAR ABOUT THAT AND I THINK --
I KNOW I KNOW THAT IT
ASSEMBLYMAN DOLLY STRONGLY
BELIEVES THAT -- THE IMPORTANCE
OF WORK AND THE DIGNITY OF WORK
FOR ALL PEOPLE AND AND BEING
ABLE TO GENERATE OPPORTUNITIES
FOR THAT IS ONE THE MOST
IMPORTANT THINGS WE CAN DO SO
THANK YOU TO ALL OF YOU.
WHO ARE SETTING UP DIFFERENT WHO
ARE WHO ARE EMPLOYING PEOPLE
WITH DISABILITIES BUT WHO ARE
SETTING UP PROGRAMS?
AND BUSINESSES THAT CAN DO IT
AND CAN DO A SUCCESS AND THRIVE
OVER TIME -- IT IS AN EASY
ANSWER A LOT OF CHALLENGES
INVOLVED -- BUT IT'S IT'S A
BLESSING AND THANK YOU.
THANK YOU BRUCE I WANTED.
FIRST OF ALL THANK BRUCE FOR
BEING HERE.
AS YOU KNOW -- THESE POSITIONS
THAT ARE STAFF WORK WAS I HAVE
TO THANK MY STAFF ANDREW AND
JENNIFER.
THEY'RE HERE ON THEIR OWN TIME.
AND WILL BE GOING TO EUREKA
TOMORROW AND HYPE BELIEVER
HEARING SATURDAY MORNING -- TO
HEAR THE FOLKS IN EUREKA IN THAT
AREA.
ON THE SAME KIND OF PROMISE OF
WHAT WE'RE DOING HERE TONIGHT --
BUT THESE FOLKS ARE HERE ON
THEIR OWN TIME -- BECAUSE THEY
CARE.
AND THEY REALLY DO CARE
[INAUDIBLE]
SO.
WHAT WAS NOT MENTIONED AND I I
HEARD A LITTLE BIT OF IT BUT
I'VE BEEN A VOLUNTEER AT THE
SPECIAL OLYMPICS FOR FIFTEEN
YEARS THE NORTHERN CALIFORNIA
GAMES?
AND OVER A FEW PAST FEW YEARS
I'VE BEEN ABLE TO RAISE FOUR
POINT SIX MILLION DOLLARS. FOR
THE GAMES SO THAT WE CAN HAVE.
AN ADD MORE HIGH SCHOOLS -- TO
THE PROGRAMS ALSO FOR THE
ATHLETES COMING UP [INAUDIBLE]
YOU'RE WELCOME.
I WANNA THINK EVERYBODY'S HERE
TONIGHT IT'S A IT'S IT'S HARD TO
GET OUT OF OUT OF YOUR HEAD OF
YOUR REGULAR YOU KNOW PATTERNS
OF LIFE.
AND TO BE HERE TO ADVOCATE FOR
SOMEBODY OR YOUR LOVED -- ONE IS
MEANS THE WORLD TO US -- I LOVE
MEETING ALL OF YOU TO AND THEN
WE'RE GONNA BE ABLE TO HAVE A
CONFERENCE CONVERSATION IF YOU'D
LIKE AND RATHER HAVE THAT RATHER
THAN A PUBLIC SETTING WILL BE
AROUND FOR A LITTLE BIT OF FOOD --
TONIGHT ALSO TO DO THAT -- BUT
WHAT ONE WOULD SAY IS THE SYSTEM
IS INJURED.
FLUCTUATING LEVELS OF SUPPORT IN
THE STATE OF THE PAST DECADE --
WHAT WE'RE GONNA HAVE TO DO IT
YOU KNOW I'M LOOKING FORWARD TO
WORKING ON THIS IS? FOR
CONSISTENCY IS STILL DO WHAT WE
DO WITH EDUCATION PROP NINETY IT
WOULD SET THE BAR HOW MUCH WE'RE
GOING TO FIND A CERTAIN ASPECT
OF A OF PROGRAM.
AND WE HAVE TO WORK TOWARDS THAT
BECAUSE FLUCTUATING UP AND DOWN
WITH AS THE POPULATION IS
GROWING.
I THINK IT'S GROWN UP OVER A
HUNDRED THOUSAND PEOPLE IN THE
LAST DECADE.
OF THAT OF THAT COME INTO THE
SYSTEM -- SO NOW WE'RE SERVICING
MORE THAN.
THREE HUNDRED TWENTY THOUSAND OF
FOLKS -- AND WE SHOULD EXPECT TO
SEE MORE.
GOING FORWARD.
WELL WE'VE SEEN YOU KNOW SOME
RECENT BUDGET AUGMENTATIONS THE
SYSTEM TO MEET NEEDS.
THIS IS JUST A TEMPORARY FIX TO
OUR LONG STANDING PROBLEMS -- SO
MEMBER HOLDEN MYSELF HELLO BILL
THIS YEAR -- THE 8% BRIDGE.
MORE OF FUNDING FOR TWO HUNDRED
AND NINETY MILLION DOLLARS.
WE'RE HOPEFULLY GOING TO BE ABLE
TO SEE THAT COME THROUGH -- WAS
A LITTLE BIT DISAPPOINTED TODAY
IN THE MAY REVISE -- HAS I DON'T
THINK THAT -- IT WAS
ACKNOWLEDGED.
OF WHERE WE'RE AT SO MY
COMMITMENT IS TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE CONTINUE I NEED TO WORK
HARDER AND SMARTER. TO BE ABLE --
TO THE THE VOICES SACRAMENTO BUT
ALSO EACH AND EVERYONE OF YOU.
ANYTHING THAT YOU FEEL THAT YOU
CAN DO TO HELP.
THE CAUSE LETTER WRITING CALLS.
WOULD BE AMAZING -- TO BE ABLE
TO TRY.
TO WHEN YOUR VOICE TO MAKE SURE
THAT YOU'RE BEING HER -- WE'RE
NOT DONE WE WILL WE'RE GONNA
CONTINUE.
I DON'T WANNA SAY FIGHT BUT I
WANT TO SAY AGGRESSIVELY PURSUE.
WHAT'S REALLY DUE TO THE
POPULATION.
AFTER MANY YEARS OF CUTS AND
UNDER FUNDING SERVICES.
YOU'RE RIGHT ABOUT.
HEARING.
THAT IN THIS PROCESS WE DO NEED
TO CREATE WHAT'S CALLED A CAREER
PATH. FOR CERTAIN SENSE OF THE
POPULATION SO THAT WE UNDERSTAND.
THAT IT.
DESERVES A LIVING WAGE IT
CREATES A RETENTION.
AND PEOPLE WHO ARE COMING INTO
THIS.
HAVE THE PASSION TO BE ABLE TO
SERVICE THE COMMUNITY THAT WE
HOLD DEAR -- AND FOR THAT.
THAT IS MY COMMITMENT ALSO IS
TRYING TO FIGURE OUT HOW WE
CREATE THOSE.
CAREER PASS LIKE WE DO NURSES
ARE NURSES AIDES OR SOMETHING OF
THAT FASHION.
WE ALSO WOULD ENCOURAGE YOU TO
PARTICIPATE IN THE SERVICE OF OF
FAMILIES BEING SERVICED BY THE
SYSTEM.
YOU CAN FIND A LINK TO THE
SURVEY ON THE SELECT COMMITTEE
FELT INTELLECTUAL AND
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES
WEBSITE -- LOOK FOR THE HAND OUT
ON THE TABLE OUT THERE ON THE
WAY OUT. TO THE LINK FOR THAT
SURVEY.
WE UTILIZE THAT TO SHARE WITH
THE DEPARTMENT OF DEVELOPMENTAL
SERVICES.
ON WHAT IS.
GOING ON IN THE REAL WORLD.
AND NOT JUST -- BITS AND PIECES
COMING TOWARDS THEM.
THE SURVEY WITH YOUR INPUT WE
WILL LEARN MORE ABOUT YOU AND
YOUR NEEDS.
ALTHOUGH WE DID HEAR YOU TONIGHT --
WE'RE ONLY STRONGER TOGETHER.
AND YOU KNOW IT IT WE HEAR ABOUT
THIS COMMON THREAD [INAUDIBLE]
OF SUPPORT.
SUPER SUPPORTIVE PARENTS WITH
PARENTS.
SUPPORT OF THE REGIONAL CENTER --
BUT WE DO KNOW.
THERE'S MUCH ROOM FOR
IMPROVEMENT.
AGAIN ONE OF THE THINGS THAT
WERE LACKING IS PROVIDERS.
I UNDERSTAND THAT.
AND I FEEL THAT WE NEED TO
REALLY MAKE AN EFFORT. TO
ENCOURAGE.
FOLKS. TO BECOME EMPLOYERS TO
BECOME PROVIDERS TO PROVIDE THE
SERVICES ARE LACKING.
BUT IT ALSO FROM THE STATE'S
PERSPECTIVE.
LIKE ANY OTHER SMALL BUSINESS
OUR BUSINESS THAT WE HAVE TO
UNDERSTAND AND MAKE SURE.
THAT THEY HAVE CERTAINTY THAT
THEY CAN MAKE A LIVING DOING
THIS JOB.
SO WHAT I WANT TO THANK YOU. FOR
BEING HERE TONIGHT -- WE'RE
GONNA DO ABOUT NINE OF THESE
HEARINGS BY THE TIME WE'RE DONE
WE'LL FINISH UP WITH ANOTHER
HEARING SACRAMENTO. TO SHARE
WITH THE COMMITTEE -- WHAT WE'VE
CLEANED IN WHAT WOULD COME
FORWARD WITH?
BUT PLEASE NEVER HESITATE TO
SHARE WITH NOT ONLY YOUR
LEGISLATURE LEGISLATURE.
YOUR SENATOR YOUR ASSEMBLY
MEMBER UP HERE.
BUT ALSO US AND HOW WE CAN
BETTER LEGISLATE HOW WE CAN
BETTER REPRESENT THE POPULATION.
BECAUSE YOU KNOW WHAT I DON'T
KNOW YOUR WORLD I'M LEARNING IT.
BUT WITHOUT YOUR HELP.
I'M NOT GONNA BE ABLE TO
ACCOMPLISH THE GOALS THAT WE ALL
WANT.
SO WITH THAT.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME.
I WANT TO THANK OUR STAFF TO DO
THE AUDIO AND AB TODAY.
AGAIN THE CITY OF READING.
IN ONE OF THE BIGGEST CHAMPIONS
ALSO IN THE ASSEMBLY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER DOLLY. ONE OF MY
GOOD FRIENDS WHO.
IS ABSOLUTE SUPPORTER OF EACH
AND EVERYONE OF YOU.
AND KNOWS THAT -- WE CAN'T DO
THIS ALONE.
HAVE A SAFE TRIP HOME TONIGHT
AND I LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING
WITH ALL ACTION ALL OF YOU.
THE REMAINDER OF MY TERMS THANK
YOU
[INAUDIBLE]
YEAH
THANK YOU
[INAUDIBLE]
YOU GUYS
.
I KNOW THAT'S EXACTLY RIGHT.
IN A WAY I GUESS I GOOD
[INAUDIBLE]
YEAH.
THAT WOULD BE
[INAUDIBLE]
ONE YEAH [INAUDIBLE]
YEAH [INAUDIBLE]
YEAH.
THESE KIND OF EVENTS
[INAUDIBLE]
YEAH
THAT WAS -- FOR SATURDAY.
SEE HOW THAT GOES I DON'T KNOW
[INAUDIBLE]
WORK OUT [INAUDIBLE]
YEAH
[INAUDIBLE]
YEAH [INAUDIBLE]
YEAH. TWO OTHER GO DOWN THERE
WERE SPLIT.
YEAH YEAH YEAH THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR BEING
.
YEAH.
YEAH YEAH.
WE DON'T BELIEVE THAT
[INAUDIBLE]
WE HAD.
OR SOMETHING.
LIKE THAT [INAUDIBLE]
ONE YEAH [INAUDIBLE]
YEAH [INAUDIBLE]
CALLING [INAUDIBLE]
FROM
. ONE OF MY COMMUNITY --
FROM.
YEAH.
YEAH YEAH.
NOTHING IN THE REST.
IT WILL BE WILL BE
[INAUDIBLE]
ONE ALL.
GOOD YEAH WHERE'S MY JANET TONIC.
LIKE SPARKLING WITH A LITTLE
[INAUDIBLE]
ONE GOOD [INAUDIBLE]
MORNING [INAUDIBLE]
MY GOSH.
REALLY GOOD I MEAN AND SO DOES
YOUR MOM BUT I REALLY.
MY SECRETIVE SECRET [INAUDIBLE]
WE YEAH.
YEAH IT MAYBE YOU.
THE ONES THAT [INAUDIBLE]
YEAH.
YEAH
-- TO AS WELL.
ALL.
THE THINGS YOU DO THIS ALRIGHT.
YEAH [INAUDIBLE]
THE STAFF.
OR THE MONEY [INAUDIBLE]
THANK YOU --
PARTICULAR
[INAUDIBLE]
YEAH [INAUDIBLE]
YEAH
.
WELL HAVE A SENIOR PARI.
ONE NINE ZERO ZERO NINE WITHIN
THE GERMAN TRANSPORTATION -- FOR
WHICH WE WERE [INAUDIBLE]
YEAH. ONE WOULD HAVE TO BE.
DATA REDUCING GROWN.
SOME OF THE MOST VALUABLE.
YEAH
[INAUDIBLE]
YEAH.
YEAH FIRST TRANSIT.
TIME. TO DO A LOT OF RESEARCH
[INAUDIBLE]
WHEN I [INAUDIBLE]
YEAH [INAUDIBLE]
OKAY [INAUDIBLE]
YEAH.
DO YOU USE EITHER YOU KNOW. ONE
PERSON MENTIONS.
PROBLEM WITH DOCTORS HATING
MEDICAL PLAN.
DO YOU DO WITH THAT MITCHELL
REVERSED GOING TO WORK.
WELL.
YEAH -- FOR THE MEDICARE PART OF
YEAH YEAH PARTNERSHIP IS ALREADY
RIGHT AROUND HERE -- SO FAMILIES
WE HAVE A YEAH.
SO WHAT THAT'S ALL PART.
THE DOCTORS TO MAKE MORE MONEY.
YEAH.
AND THE DIFFERENT THINGS RESULTS
YEAH I'LL TELL YOU MORE THAN
MEDICAL.
AND REQUIRED RECORDS.
YEAH.
IF YOU WANT NOW [INAUDIBLE]
YEAH [INAUDIBLE]
EVERYTHING WENT [INAUDIBLE]
LIKE
.
THERE'S ALWAYS THE NORMAL YEAH.
YEAH YEAH THE GOVERNMENT IF
YOU'LL BE GETTING ON THE ONLY
[INAUDIBLE]
YEAH [INAUDIBLE]
YEAH YEAH.
YES IS A MODEL BUT WAS NOT RIGHT
[INAUDIBLE]
YEAH [INAUDIBLE]
ALL.
PROBLEM IS I DO.
EVERYBODY JOB YEAH [INAUDIBLE]
ZERO YEAH [INAUDIBLE]
YEAH THE YEAH.
SO -- THEY ARE ABLE [INAUDIBLE]
YEAH.
IT'S GOING TO PUT THAT IN MY
FAMILY HERE IN THE IS.
YOU SHOULD BE ABLE TO AS A
POSSIBLE [INAUDIBLE]
WELL RIGHT [INAUDIBLE]
THE HOTEL [INAUDIBLE]
YEAH [INAUDIBLE]
NO YEAH [INAUDIBLE]
WELL.
FOR THERE'S YEAH YEAH WHAT'S
HAPPENING IS YEAH -- YEAH.
THERE'S A LITTLE.
I MEAN YEAH THERE'S REALLY
SOMETHING TO BE SAID ABOUT.
YEAH SHOP.
I THINK THAT'S WHAT HAS ME.
THE LADIES AND IT'S LIKE.
JUST LIKE WHAT IS GOING TO BE.
AND THEN ONE OF THOSE YOU SEE
WHY WE WERE LIKE THAT BY ME BUT
WE NEED.
MORE ANGLES ORDER [INAUDIBLE]
YEAH.
THIS IS THE GUY WHO IS DOING
THIS YOU ARE MY JOB.
YEAH YEAH THE DISEASE
[INAUDIBLE]
YEAH.
I DIDN'T WANT TO WEAR A LOT OF
THE GOAL THAT IS THE ACTION ITEM
IS TO FIND A WAY.
I DIDN'T LOG IN ORLANDO IN THE
SENSE OF LIKE YOU CAN SEE